as the protests continue
erupting in communist-controlled cuba
the communists have finally had enough
and they have reportedly opened fire on
what is described as a peaceful protest
actually killing somebody there's a
bunch of other very
disturbing witness accounts and there's
a bit of hearsay
in one story a man claims that his
friend was calling him saying the police
are rounding people up
they're secretly arresting people
they're beating people in the streets
and you know what i gotta say
i believe it you know why the cubans
shut down the internet so people
couldn't spread the word
they arrested a journalist live on air
while this journalist was giving an
interview
to a spanish news anchor if the people
of cuba
really believed in their revolution
certainly the social media they would
put out would be
dramatically in favor of what was going
on with the cuban government
so why would they need to silence the
people of cuba unless it turns out
the information coming out was desperate
please for help as the police brutally
crack down on anybody who opposes their
authoritarian regime
well we got that we've got threats from
russia and china and iran
over u.s potential actions in cuba of
course you heard we talked about it last
night i believe we talked about it
the mayor of miami saying we should
potentially have
airstrikes in cuba man this is
escalating rather
rather quickly and then you've got south
africa massive food shortages are only
getting worse because of the widespread
riding across the country
i think the death toll may be over 100
at this point i'm not entirely sure
there's another interesting article
though mit somebody
predicted in 1972 that uh by 2040
the economy the system society would
collapse and now they're saying
we're on track for that so add that to
the list we've got the fourth turning
we've got the acidity strap and now
we've got some mit report
okay the apocalypse is happening well
we'll talk all about it joining us today
is of course jack besovic
welcome welcome everyone we are here for
the fourth turning we are going to
document it in full we're going to talk
about
the axis of the elites between the ccp
the one percent of china and the one
percent of the u.s forming a global
overstate
listening to what biden was saying
earlier today i don't i don't said it
today actually
he said the other day i think he said
it's not just the vote what do you say
the votes don't matter anymore it's
who who counts the vote or something
like that something like that that's
what i said
that quote that stalin was accredited
with yeah yeah well i i saw the one
where he was saying you know we've
counted and recounted
there's never been an election that was
scrutinized more highly than this and
i'm like
do you not remember the year 2000 joe
because i remember you going around for
years afterwards saying
al gore won the election al gore won the
election he he said this and i remember
i remember hanging chads i remember the
you know having the magnifying glass up
did they fill out this bubble
did they fill out that bubble well
perhaps they actually meant to fill out
the bubble
in between them yeah so yeah no no we
we've had a very highly scrutinized
election in the past joe i just want to
add something you know because a lot of
people were like
for the past several years when i would
mention civil war they'd be like
tim you're so dumb why are you bringing
it up joe biden is now repeatedly
referring to
the right as akin to confederates saying
over and over again we face the biggest
challenge to our democracy since the
civil war that's no joke how many times
has said that now like several times so
this is something that i've picked up
this is a rhetorical device
that is not being used by accident by
not just joe biden but really his entire
white house and the entire
administration there
there is a reason that they keep
referring to
civil war there is a reason they keep
referring to their political opponents
as the confederates who are essentially
traitors right traitors to the republic
traders to the union
in the in in the time there is a very
direct goal that they are seeking not
only
in the immediate term right in terms of
the the basic political win
but also they are in search of
a crackdown they are in search of they
have a solution
and they are just waiting for the
problem to manifest itself that's right
um they know they're hanging onto power
by a thread
so they need an excuse for physical
force
intelligence agencies everyone to just
shut it down and seize full control but
we'll get into all this we got uh we got
ian chillin yeah yeah that january 16th
i feel like their response was a little
extreme and i it's still
they're still responding to it they
occupied washington dc for months
yeah i was there i couldn't park my car
yeah that's creepy stuff that's going on
man
crazy crazy we don't even our capital
was occupied
by by military forces and we don't even
talk about it it was earlier this year
right we didn't even talk about that
they only just took the fences down
right they wanted
they wanted crew served gun emplacements
do you remember that story that's right
they actually wanted that and i believe
was pelosi who was saying that
was saying we do do we need crew served
guns up there just in
case of what right there was never any
intelligence and they would have them up
there and a few republicans every once
in a while when chris ray would come up
and they would say
do you have any intel can you tell us
what what the threats are can tell us
what's going on
now interestingly enough on april 2nd
there actually was
a terrorist attack at the u.s capitol
however it was conducted by a guy
who was not a follower of you know q
anon
or maga no it was a guy who was actually
a follower of the nation of islam and
lewis farrakhan
and by the way he actually murdered a
capital police officer the only capital
police officer
to be to be murdered in the line of duty
since the 1990s what was the date do you
remember
i believe it was april second fourth two
so i was going at the four two yeah we
gotta call four two four four it's my
birthday yeah four two baby
all right all right i was down the
street i was actually down the street
when it happened we'll we'll we'll get
in all that we got to
we got lydia president your birthday i'm
here in the corner yes it is ian's
birthday
happy birthday i'm sorry thanks lydia
that's a bit of a downer
but yeah all right before we get started
everybody go to timcast.com become a
member we're gonna have a members only
segment coming up
after the show usually goes around 11 or
so but if it goes late it goes late you
know because we want to make sure we get
you the best of the best that content
but uh good news it looks like our
soft date right now is for a monday
launch of the new site which you've
probably seen
we've actually got some of the alpha
articles already you're going to see
them tonight if you're watching on
youtube
and they look absolutely incredible
there's more to come your support at
timcast.com means
we're we're we're taking over the media
baby we're going to be hiring more and
more journalists we're going to be
hiring fact checkers i'm going to be
creating a fact checking division i've
long talked about our plans for what
we're doing with fact checking and it's
all coming
so again temperamentcast.com become a
member don't forget like this video
subscribe to this channel hit that
notification bell all apparently that
it does nothing but hey you know do it
anyway
and uh share the content share this
video share this show share it with word
of mouth
through links whatever you got to do and
do it for all of the other shows you
really like as well all the other
craters
that's how we overcome the censorship
unless or until they ban us so
sure whatever but let's let's jump into
this first story talking about communist
cuba
is where it's getting dark man daily
mail reports quote the communists have
lost control first cuban demonstrator is
killed after police
quote open fire on peaceful protest
while anti-government reporter is
arrested live on tv
as unrest continues de ubis lorencio
tajeda 36 died monday in a suburb of
havana
during a clash between protesters and
police witnesses claimed security forces
had responded to demonstrators with
gunfire
after they threw rocks social media
activist dina stars was arrested
live on tv by cuban security forces on
tuesday
cuban government launched crackdown on
protest after large-scale demonstrations
erupted on sunday
seems to be getting worse man i don't
know you seem to know a lot about
communists though jack
what's happening in cuba yeah so um you
know i
i funny enough is i always joke about
this so i spent
almost a year right in cuba when i was
at guantanamo but
because when i was there under the obama
administration we didn't have status
forces agreement we still don't have a
status force agreement between the us
and cuba in terms of that so we were not
allowed actually out
into the island right so we used to have
these t-shirts that we would sell on
base that said
uh you're here in cuba close but no
cigar
and um and so i've always kind of wanted
to actually visit the rest of the island
but i got really into
just how cuba works when i was there
studying it because
needless to say let's just say that you
know well i was there for uh the
detainee operations we also had people
who were there from an intel side that
were not
paying attention to them they were
paying attention to the broader you know
cuba the landscape there the military
the politics
and and of course we actually had some
communication with them we would say
across the fence
uh just in terms of hey if there's you
know uh because it's very arid there on
that part of cuba because the mountains
so you know uh wildfires was a big issue
just like in california so
that's something obviously would affect
both sides so it just makes sense to
kind of have a monthly
meeting where we sit down and talk yeah
and you would
so what you're seeing now basically is
look the castros are essentially over
right raul castro has you know he's on
his last legs he's kind of cut ties
he abdicated the throne right he's gone
he's gone and so
they know that this that the new
leadership who by the way who is still
on twitter verified and able to tweet
right throughout all everything you just
said everything cracking down on
protesters
shooting killing them uh arresting
journalists
in the middle of the street he is
allowed to tweet but donald trump of
course is banned who is it
this is the cuban leader you're saying
that the leader yeah what's the right
what's his name
who is it what's his name i i forgot his
name man let's find out
the man of the hour you said the status
of force agreement jack is that
something that the government will
officially do with another government
when they are going to have military
that is going to be out and about
right so right so you need some kind of
legal uh
you need essentially a legal purpose for
being there so uh you look at a country
where the us has overseas bases
uh on a more normal with a country where
we have more normalized relations
so talk about south korea germany japan
those are kind of like the three big
ones
also uh uk we have we have some people
there and on a few bases
um and so you would have an essential
agreement where okay
we are not immigrating we don't need
visas right we don't need
uh any specific um documentation other
than the orders right and that's all
covered under that status of forces
agreement so
um you know of course and you know the
sort of cynical view of that is like
this is
u.s imperialism right why does the us
need these all of these bases around the
world
why are they providing this blanket of
of international
security this is the way that russia
would describe it this way that china
certainly describes it especially when
it comes to uh east asia and that sphere
but this is that's the basic idea that
status of force agreement and you'll
also see this in terms of like
you know if you're going over somewhere
for a uh you know an exercise like we do
exercises with
with tons of of of militaries and so the
idea or tons of countries around the
world thailand
australia etc and so the idea is that
you wouldn't necessarily need a visa to
go because you're going on on orders
going on mission
is it the end of the world we got we got
china china war planes in taiwan we got
south africa is collapsing
you got the revolt in cuba then you've
got in the u.s
haiti as well i mean the truth gets
assassinated
it's like we we actually kind of drove
past that it's like
the president of haiti is assassinated
everyone just kind of says uh you know
it's haiti
well well actually no what happened was
the president of haiti gets assassinated
and everyone's like
whoa what's happening and then all of a
sudden everyone turns because south
africa lights up cuba lights up
so look man fourth turning it might not
be a world war what if it's a global
economic collapse
miguel diaz-canel by the way yeah yeah i
have a i have a black rock right here
i got you a black rock what you're
seeing what you're seeing now
is by the way it this is a reformation
of the global order
right this is a reformation because uh
for a variety of reasons
america which as you know as i
delineated before
which had maintained that system and you
can see the military power but also the
economic power
and the cultural power of the united
states all of those
have become diminished over the past
decade and really over the past couple
of years
now uh in in the trump years you know
there was this sort of like sudden
resurgence people are saying hey is the
us going to go back to that position
but then that you know that that was
basically usurped by biden and so that
that
path seems to be closed and now people
are realizing they are going back into
what the status quo priority was
prior to trump which will end the phrase
i'm going to say and you'll all remember
it
this was managed decline right we were
told this again and again throughout the
obama years the u.s is headed toward a
managed decline and
we were told you they used all these
technocratic phrases to sort of explain
well this is just the way
you know things are going and countries
you know they they rise and they fall
and this is this is normal and you know
i believe in american exceptionalism the
same way greeks believe in greek
exceptionalism etc etc that was the
quote famous quote from barack obama
so this is the idea and i want people to
understand that this is being done
by policy this is being done by
decisions right human decisions human
agency that's made
on behalf of the people in power that
have made this decision they've made the
decision to
outsource right u.s jobs which is
outsourcing our manufacturing base which
is outsourcing our wealth
all of the secondary and tertiary
industries and businesses and
communities that would have thrived off
that i was actually just up in
in maine we went up for the fourth of
july and
you know it's it's great because you can
go on the coast and there's all these
sort of like old money cities and old
money like beach towns
and you go 30 minutes away and it's all
uh this post-industrial
just bleak societies where you know
former factory towns where the factory's
gone
and the the workers the families the
workers are all still there wondering
hey what
what do we do now right we're still here
and
you know we we'd like to stay in our
towns but we're just stuck
it's all it's all done that's the
interesting thing about policy
you can you can be an industrialist you
can run a factory and through no
like no fault of your own the government
decides they're going to put pressure on
your business that forces it
to leave the country so of course it
still comes down to the conscious
decisions of a lot of these you know
people who run these companies
but when they say something like we're
going to increase the minimum wage
we're going to increase the corporate
tax then we're going to do a free trade
agreement for factories outside
it's impossible to compete let's say you
make
uh ian you gave me this little was it
obsidian that is obsidian is volcanic
glass this is obsidian yeah wow that's
that and
how do they they file it to this all
right they polish it but let's say
you you have a you have an obsidian
factory and you make these fancy little
obsidians
we're talking all right and you operate
in uh
hawaii new jersey new jersey and then
they announced
volcanic new jersey yeah well they
import all the volcanic rocks
naturally so they announced they're
going to be raising the minimum wage
raising the corporate taxes and at the
same time free trade agreements with
manufacturing from china too much for my
company
and you say you know what my workers
deserve fifteen dollars an hour i do so
i i
gladly accept the cost increase and i
should pay my fair share in taxes
all right so you go over the numbers and
say to pay everyone fifteen dollars an
hour and pay at twenty percent
tax we're gonna have to charge five
dollars for every
beautiful obsidian stone no problem
right then all of a sudden you go to
walmart and there's
china stone for three dollars and you
say there's literally no way we can make
the obsidian stones for three dollars
well china has slaves wow and they can
import these products for
free with no charge so your company goes
out of business because it's impossible
to compete
with the free the slave labor that
you're trying to use and understand
right this was the idea this was
actually the plan all the way back
before when
and and funnily enough right prior to
occupy wall street what was the big you
know i talked about antifa light wrote
the whole book about antifa
um what was the big sort of antifa
moment
right it was the battle of seattle 1999
wto and the wto and it was all about
who getting into the wto it was all
about china getting into the wto
over slave labor and that was antifa
right protesting
against china and violently very very
violently rioting
china getting into wtf those were gen
xers so
a big thing at play here is gen x was
protesting at the battle in seattle in
99 and they were flying tibetan flags
that was second wave antiques
yeah exactly i wouldn't call them antifa
they were they were
anti-free trade like it was it was it
was more classically liberal out of ways
but they were leftists
and then 10 years goes by and you get a
little bit more than 10 years 12 years
you get occupy wall street what's that
millennials with some gen xers who were
at the wto but many of those gen xers
the wta moved on had families got jobs
and they're gone
now the millennials come in it's been 10
years
since occupy wall street 10 years not
crazy it'll be 10 years in two months
nine nine uh september 17th 2011. park
that was nice now it's gen z people who
are 10 years old during occupy who have
no idea what it was about
are now in their 20s entering their 20s
and they're voting for people and they
know nothing about the obama
administration
that's why i talk about the federal
reserve like a chicken with my head cut
off on this show because we got to teach
these people about
what is what is at least part of the
root cause of social disorder right now
and it's i think it's the the
privatization of our monetary supply bro
look
you jack talks about the plan the wto in
99. again this
is because it all goes back to it man so
but but it's
it's as i explained how you think that
joe biden doesn't know what he's doing
he's called for those three things
specifically we're gonna raise
the minimum wage and we're gonna
increase corporate tax so they pay their
fair share and then
free trade agreements and you wonder why
all those things come together
it's to make sure you can't run your
business now here's the thing
these people who were 10 years old
during occupy wall street weren't even
alive during the battle in seattle
during the wto stuff
right now they don't know any of this
now all they know is they're growing up
and the system is broken and the
government should give them free stuff
and when you try to explain to them
dude it's biden he's been doing this for
50 years to go
shut up fascist did you see that they're
going to be giving
families 300 per kid yes for until their
child
tax credit this is how we afford this
how do we we can't
so they're just gonna print more money
bro have you seen the consumer price
index
what was the percentage it said it's
like five point something it's going up
right
gas is up forty five percent it's insane
inflation bind inflation inflation we're
gonna we're gonna it's it's
it's you know they they call what do
they call it uh uh massive monetary
theory
and modern monetization moderatory
theory modern monetary theory but it's
not modern monetary theory anymore now
it's modern monetary practice
right it's we can spend forever we can
spend indefinitely
we can and when you hear the fed say oh
we're gonna we're adding to our balance
sheet we're adding to the fed balance
sheet right
right well that means you are taking on
debt which means when you're taking on
the debt you're issuing what you're
you're
issuing loans to banks at the highest
level right the reason that they are
doing this
is because they want all of you they
want millennials they want gen z
to become a renter class right you right
they
want you you'll own nothing they you'll
live in the pod you'll eat the bugs
right you will own nothing and you'll be
happy right
that doesn't mean that no one owns
everything right
someone is going to own something
someone and that someone as we're
finding out now is going to be wall
street
that's going to be blackrock it's going
to be blackstone it's going to be these
massive companies that are coming in now
and purchasing what real estate so your
landlord
right let's you know we know how much
antifa love communism right yeah exactly
so you have corpianism where these
corporations
from wall street are now controlling the
land they're controlling your real
estate they're
if you want to go out and so and this is
the amazing part of it because rent's
just going to go up
and so who's paying for those loans the
renter is
you are you are going to be a russian
surf
look how brilliant the whole college
plan was
everybody must go to college two things
happen when they went to college
they took on massive debt they can't pay
back and they can't declare bankruptcy
on
and they got indoctrinated with
psychotic you know cult bs they told
everybody to take it on
at the very least if they don't
indoctrinate you they make you an
indentured servant
now they're buying up all the houses so
if you want to live somewhere
they're going to say but you got to pay
us rent hey we're a private company
if you want to live in my house you got
to pay the rent and then when you give
them problems they'll say we're raising
your rent
oh no and you get kicked out it is so
where are you going to go how are you
going to
how are you going to have any type of
wealth formation if you don't have
wealth formation
how are you going to uh support a family
god forbid and if you do
somehow manage to be able to get married
to have a couple of kids
how are you even going to be able to
generate enough wealth to pass something
on to them
so you create into something the left i
used to talk about all the time
generational wealth right dude you're
not going to be able to do that
with the negative interest rates the way
they are now this is all
done by design and the manufacturing
where does it go it goes to asia why
because they don't have our labor laws
you have you have slaves essentially
slave labor in china in xinjiang with
the uyghurs
that are building all this stuff so they
don't have to worry about them they're
not getting the wealth the wealth is
going into the one percent of china and
who is that that's the ccp and this is
gets back to my earlier point before
when when we talked about the battle of
seattle when when
people were talking about putting uh and
this was this was clinton right this was
clinton putting
china into the wto and then later bush
41 bush 43 bush 41 talked about this of
course the response to
tiananmen square he said well we just
need to bring china into the global
order
that was what was said again and again
and again people were saying tiananmen
square
they're crushing students the same way
that people are being crushed the
protesters in cuba right now
bring them into the global order bring
them into the global order
and they'll become more open they'll
become more socially liberal they'll
become more transparent
no it was the exact opposite that
happened but
i think we became more authoritarian but
i i think we're always more
authoritarian
i think you just can't do it instantly
so look at what's happening now with
what joe biden's saying about
civil war stuff i mean the way he's
describing people on on one six the
insurrectionists
the confederates never breached our
capital come on man
and then you hear what he talks about
the the fbi saying snitching your
neighbors
you you we're hearing that joe biden
wouldn't have to so
there's there's that refrain too that i
believe people will say that
you know if if the situation were
hopeless the propaganda would be
unnecessary
joe biden's not going to philadelphia
not going to
you know where i'm where i'm from and
giving a massive speech
standing across the constitution centers
down across independence mall from
in the actual site of the signing of the
declaration in the constitution
he's not going to give a speech like
that from a position of strength
that was done from a position of
weakness that's because
the contradictions are accelerating too
fast right now the hegelian dialectic
which the left used to move forward they
used to progress with
is happening too fast and not enough
people
are able to keep up with it that's why
they realize that their critical mass is
falling apart
you mentioned on twitter that uh i don't
know i don't know
how how much you've confirmed this or
not but that there was a plan to put
together a list of
extremists oh yeah the insurrectionists
followed on social media can you can you
tell us about what is that all about so
the reporting that i've got on that so
far it comes from a high-level white
house official
who's sending me this stuff and is
saying that it's actually being driven
by three people right now
chris ray nancy pelosi and chuck schumer
and uh ron clayne in the white house is
going along with it jill biden is going
along with it and for the time being joe
biden is going along with it
i haven't actually been able to confirm
whether or not commonwealth is for
against this
but what it is is they're going through
the
jan six defendants and they're trying to
cross-reference
everybody from that in terms of their
social media and come up with kind of
like a top ten or a tie i haven't been
able to confirm how many it is or how
far it's going
but find who the top people they were
following on social media was
and then the those of those people and i
said well what is it
are you going for the actual people who
are saying storm the capital or
uh commit some act of violence no no no
no they're going for the people who are
saying who were trying to
just say hey show up on january 6
because the president is going to give a
speech on the south lawn and at the oval
it's going
lips they're specifically putting lots
of people who said come to dc come to dc
interesting yeah so if you promoted that
event which of course was a speech from
the president of the united states right
this was not
the thing that happened afterwards then
you are essentially going to be put on
this thing and
then you are going to this is going to
be said now and go with the report in
bloomberg
right bloomberg is saying that mike
lindell of all people because he had
that
comment about august and everything that
they're saying we're now
tracking to see whether or not people
commit via this fbi
in bloomberg saying we need to be
careful about august because we think
that there will be
extremist attacks because mike lindell
who
sells pillows right um is is talking
about august and so august might be a
key date
for the extremists i i got to tell you
man um
there's a lot of people who want to want
to show optimism you know we got steve
bannon and michael mouse who both said
they've been very optimistic
but what we're watching i mean it tracks
very similarly to the rise of any
authoritarian regime
of the past several hundred years and it
doesn't look like we're getting our
we're gonna we're gonna walk out of this
one it looks like we're gonna be
underneath the boot on this one
so the question always comes down to
that critical mass
right it it will there be some kind of
conflict
probably hopefully that it will be a
political conflict in terms
of uh it's done through words it's done
through elections and we can steer clear
of anything
beyond that um that being said that
being said though i do think there's a
reason
that joe biden keeps talking about civil
war again there is not a day that goes
by
that you do not hear someone from the
white house saying the phrase civil war
or making some kind of reference to it
i'd go back all the way through
why i i believe they're trying to call
their punch
i believe they're trying to call their
punch what do you mean call their punch
they want
this is what i was saying before they
want to be in a position where they can
crack down
they want to be in a position where they
have some kind of
inciting event right you know in in
narrative fiction
shot hard event right they want to shout
her around the world they want
something terrible like this and you can
go by the way
so they can stop trump they can stop
that they can stop they can stop 20 24.
and beyond that they want to stop the
populist movement they want to shut like
ever since the internet
really kind of came out and then
internet 2.0 with the rise of social
media came out
um it became a very big problem for the
people who said who used to be able to
just control the narrative right none of
this could have happened in the 90s by
the way and so
for the you know the gen z types out
there who are watching this saying oh
well i
you know i don't remember any of that
battle seattle et cetera in the 90s
there were like
five tv channels and a couple of
newspapers and if you wanted to control
the narrative it was very easy that's
why
you know i think for a lot of people who
are younger um iraq wmd's that was kind
of like the last
you know the last sort of time where it
worked where just a lot of people said
well
you know what the government says
there's there's wmds in iraq i mean i
guess we gotta but everybody was saying
everybody's saying it there's no right
because those other i mean you might be
able to find like
uh you know a certain am radio host uh
who was around at the time
um who who would probably be speaking
out against that but that was probably
it right there was no other form of mass
media we don't even use that phrase
anymore by the way mass media because
everybody
through social media has the capacity to
be mass media think about that that's
interesting interesting
everybody all you need is this and you
can be mass media you know we do that
new vlog we do a lot of we use a lot of
our phones to film it
people probably don't realize we have
good cameras and then we just use phones
i always say the the greatest journalist
of 2016 was uh zidane garza
the guy who was a firefighter on his day
off on 911
who decided to go to the memorial and
then got that video of hillary passing
out
when everybody in the world said that it
wasn't happening but what did he do
he had the wherewithal and he had the
mental preparedness to say
i'm going to turn my camera i'm going to
film this and then
right and this is this is the spark of
just just history this is the spark of
the turn of history i'm going to upload
it to my twitter account
and then some and you only had a couple
thousand followers but it was enough
that it generated more and more and then
it became i really do think that was the
day she lost the election
you're saying that they want to call
their punch and think about everything
biden's been doing it's not just
saying civil war over and over again
it's that you know the fbi comes out and
says you're in a position
catch the extremists and your family and
your friends you've got the fbi saying
white supremacists are the biggest
threat
they're saying these things over and
over and over again even though it's not
backed up by any real data or any real
news
because you repeat the lie enough people
start to believe it's true
but they're planting the seeds right and
then you've also got if you can see this
in
in the the documents that are coming out
from doj and all this
they've got people in facebook chat
rooms they've got people in telegrams
they've got informants all over the
place
uh it just came out buzzfeed of all
people buzzfeed just said that the
michigan plot had 12
fbi informants yeah involved 17 people
right right 12 fbi informants so here's
what happens
a year from now that's buzzfeed that's
not like you know a year from now
something happens and they'll be like
see we told you
yeah right like a year goes by and
they're just waiting like any one day
and these 365
it's actually you know i'll put it this
way um
do you remember the simpsons episode
where uh homer had it turns out he
hasn't paid his taxes so they asked him
to go undercover on his friends
yeah and then hit so they put a wire on
him and it's and it's like like this
huge box under his shirt and
he's walking around moe's and he says he
says so
you guys committing any crimes right now
and they're like they're like homer do
you mean like the time that you were
countered
that you were counterfeit trying to
counterfeit money yeah but it was like
no i mean like stuff that involves
you you know that time like and then
they give more examples yeah and like
and i think mo
has like a killer whale in the back room
or something
and all these like these like japanese
guys and he's like he's like get rid of
it get ready get out of here
guys get out of here that's what the
democrats are doing right so that's
i mean it you know and it's and i laugh
but it's it's that's kind of what's
going on right now
it is that you you have a solution in
search of a problem by the way
this is something that i saw in the
intelligence community um
when i was in there that as the war on
terror was wound down you had all of
these you know they would say capacities
right you had all of these
teams you had all these special
operations forces you had all these
super high-powered intelligence programs
collection programs all designed to what
protect america from terrorism right
but as the war on terror is winding down
you have all of these toys
right and yet you don't have any
authority to use them anywhere so you
have to say well
and you have all these people who have
joined saying hey i need to defend the
country i've been told we have all this
gucci hardware these gucci
programs i've gone to this training i've
gone to that training what do you mean i
can't go
kick down some doors what do you mean i
can't go after somebody i've got to go
after someone there's got to be somebody
out there right
when you be when you are a hammer you
view
everyone as a nail right and so you have
a supply and demand
problem when it came to what terrorism
and now they are trying to turn
that on its head and say the biggest
terrorism threat is not overseas anymore
it's right here behind every blade of
grass but i think that has a lot to do
with the midterms
and with donald trump running again they
will they will by any means necessary
stop republicans and trump from winning
that's a lot of collateral damage
yep do you think that they would do that
right now they have
they're they're hanging on to power by a
hair they have the senate only by the
tiebreaker vote
and they have what 11 votes in the house
i think so it's close yeah it's close
so 2022 comes up i mean look we saw
republicans win safe
democrat districts in in 2020. this
could be the republicans taking back the
house and as i said the republicans
they won't but they should immediately
impeach joe biden for
all of the like we look if they could
impeach trump over a phone call with
ukraine we got way more than that about
joe biden with ukraine and mexico and
all the other garbage he did with his
son hunter
but the republicans get that house they
can start filing subpoenas they can do
what the democrats did
now the democrats aren't going to let
that happen not to mention the
republicans probably wouldn't do it
anyway because they're
really really weak but the democrats
don't want
that kind of that all depends on which
republicans end up winning these prime
ministers
the primary fight is so big right now is
and you look at some of these states not
only
in the house races but in the senate
races where because republicans know
they have a very good chance of taking
back the senate
uh that's why you've got stuff that's
heating up in missouri in arizona
in ohio these are all places where
people either look at it as a potential
republican pickup
or a you've got a republican that's
leaving um wisconsin
may or may not with portman we're not
sure i know he said that he's he's not
going to run again but actually
i don't know if i'm like breaking news
here but he's that he may actually
uh run for re-election in wisconsin but
um and you've got strong candidates
right you know people are
i'm constantly getting people to say hi
jack take you know you should take a
side with this guy and get excited with
that guy i said look i
i think there's a lot of strong
candidates um and i think i hear a lot
of people saying the right things just
just like you're saying that
you've got younger republicans now who
are stepping up saying look i don't want
to just win
to say that i won the race i want to be
in charge
in the texas governor's primary that's
why abbott is is facing some of this
stuff because they're saying
i actually you know i i you know not a
texan but i never i never thought of
abbott as some kind of rhino
but now you've got people going up
against him saying how come you didn't
pass an election law a decade ago how
come you didn't pass this law back then
if in the midterms enough right
populists win and displace
neocon and establishment republicans
then they might actually start doing
stuff imagine if
every seat taken is by a marjorie taylor
green or a lauren bober or matt gates
right so this is
a freak out this is something where you
know i've got to give credit where
credit's due you look
at the dsa the democrat socialists of
america
and the way the squad kind of rose up
out of the dsa and rose up out of their
sort of talking points
it's almost like what they did is they
created kind of like um
how major league baseball has their has
the minor leagues right it's it's sort
of like a farm
team where people can compete people can
move up their way of
up in the ranks and then as they get up
into congress
they then are beholden to all of that
stuff that they had to go through when
they came up through the dsa
well the right doesn't have anything
like that the right has has no
organizations like that whatsoever
uh that may be changing but from this
point on it's just more like it's kind
of more of a free-for-all
but i do see that as a potential model
for people on the right or for just
people who are populous in general to
say look
we are going to have our own
organizations that are
maybe have a tenuous affiliation with
you know one side or the other
but what they really serve to to do is
to credential people
is to bring them up through the ranks is
to give you know kind of like put them
through the ringer
you know here and there and then when it
comes to actually running
we are going to say okay i know who this
person is because i knew them from you
know all those years so let's go back to
you know what the democrats are doing or
the binding administration specifically
targeting
people with this terrorism i think it's
because that's the point if
if enough strong republicans young
energetic and populist republicans get
in
they're gonna have tremendous power in
the house that could be very very
disruptive to the very
flimsy amount of power the democrats are
a flimsy threat they're holding on by
so how do you stop it well you
continually say that the republicans are
insurrectionists they're
they're the problem they support trump
this proves it
and they try and do everything in their
power to use the government to go after
those who might actually upset
their power they want to solidify their
power and control
they need one more senate seat to
actually firmly have the senate
so they're going to demonize in every
possible way and there's a lot of people
i know and you guys probably know people
like this
who are just really dumb don't care
about politics
here in the background on cnn believe it
yeah
unfortunately yes and they vote it is
sad to me so you think that they're
the democrats are going at this
politically like if we can
suppress this this insurrection then
we'll stay in office and retain power
but that there's also like a global
organization
uh that wants to buy your stuff so that
it can rent it back to you
that's using this opportunity well
there's international interests
certainly
who want to own things and make money
off it i i think of it more like
um a fire you know or rot
it's not like there's one guy who's
toying his mustache going yeah
like klaus schwab everyone assumes he's
you know he's influential for sure and a
lot of these wealthy people george shows
are influential
but it's applied pressure enough
powerful people
want a similar thing and they're
applying pressure in a similar direction
and so the fires of that elitism keep
burning
so if you have it's it's like if you
have 10 people
in a country and they're all wealthy
industrialists and seven of them are
communists
well they're going to keep funding
communists not together as a conspiracy
just because seven of them are
communists eventually then the people
who have food
and money and are reproducing are
communists and then the three who
support the capitalists or the free
market for enterprise people
they don't have as much success so then
the culture becomes dominated by
communism
it's part of the problem of doing
nothing they say if good men do nothing
that's like
worse than evil itself it's because when
you do nothing then kids are born and
they're raised in an environment where
psychosis
is the norm like occupation of iraq and
afghanistan
and so they think it's okay like they're
twisted these no offense
if you were born after the year 2000 but
if you didn't see what happened on 9 11
and if you didn't read the evidence
about that in the years afterwards and
the weapons of mass destruction and
watch
the the slow decline into occupation
that the united states has become
it was terrifying it was disgust it was
revolting and it still is
let's let's let's talk about where we're
at externally right
so it's not just the democrats are
terrible
with domestic policy let me show you the
story we got right here from newsweek
russia china iran warn u.s must not
intervene in cuba that's right don't you
dare united states intervene in cuba
because
russia and china and iran have have said
so because russia would never intervene
in cuba
oh for sure there's no history of that
remember when the u.s surrendered to
iran
a couple about two years ago some small
ships were forced to surrender
gunships yeah um i was in the navy the
day that happened
and seeing that image
of my my fellow sailors in in the same
uniform
that i know i was i was in um in the
pacific when that happened they were in
the gulf
and we we were serving in similar
communities put it that way so
like i you know they were i was like one
degree moved from some of those guys
and at that time you know we were still
at on edge with north korea we're
certainly always on edge with china
um it would not have taken much
to see people i knew or you know various
missions
to you know kind of see myself in that
position and thinking that
you know that image right of american
sailors on their knees with their hands
behind their heads
to iran of all countries to iran and to
not have a secretary of state
and a president who were immediately
getting on television or picking up the
phone and saying well this was trump
no no that was that was obama 2019 was
when we had the surrender
when which turned are you talking about
i'm pretty sure it was two years ago
i'm talking about the one in 2016. what
was what happened in that one year 2016
that was the one where they were held
for a couple of days
in in the gulf um and they actually were
on their knees hands behind their heads
and is the one where you were in the
mediterranean tim oh no you're right
you're right 2016.
yeah that was that was january 16.
you're right wow um what was the story
by the way were they
sailing too close out of international
waters they went to iranian water so
there is an island called farsi island
in that's
essentially in the middle of the gulf
which so the the gulf is split right now
right so there's there's
um international waters but then when
you get into uh what a country is called
in their economic exclusion zone
that would essentially be considered uh
iranian waters
however this island which is in the
middle
is an iranian island so they have
sovereignty over that so there is an eez
around that island as well and uh their
ship i believe
in the official report it came out they
actually ran out of fuel because the the
junior officer on there
did not didn't actually calculate the
fuel that they would need for the
journey they were going from
the northern the northern gulf all the
way down to bahrain
and they didn't compute it correctly et
cetera et cetera right it's supposed to
be the swing and then you go around the
island run out of fuel
drift into the waters get picked up but
i said hey
and they say hey you're invading our
waters and they say oh excuse me this is
just you know it's a big mistake it's
huge understanding
nope this is this is a u.s invasion but
you look at the response now
this is why when you when you said it
was trump said no no no if this would
imagine trump on twitter right if
if the irs gcc if the iranian
revolutionary guard had picked up some
of our sailors and even had even
considered
getting close right we are this is trump
by the way who actually did just
straight up
merc an iranian general like the leader
right of of their um
of their force the cuds force which is
like they're it's kind of like they're
still team six in many ways
uh but but far beyond that because
they're terrorists as well um
obama i mean we're so sorry
we're so sorry what do you think the
response from this administration has
been following uh these threats from
you know communists i mean iran you know
russia and china sure
but uh what did jenseki say she refused
gensaki
refuses to admit communism is the reason
behind cuba's freedom protests and joe
biden
others in his administration said it was
about coven they won't
actually confront the issue they won't
actually
speak to the public honestly about
what's going on in cuba so this is
actually scared
this is actually a situation where uh
you know biden who you know and i i'll
give him some advice i don't think he'll
take it
but if he wanted to be smart this is a
chance where you could stand
up for us leadership for the hem this is
monroe doctrine this is
excuse me this is the caribbean right
this is nowhere near china
this is nowhere near russia this is our
backyard
you don't tell us what we're going to do
here right
that's not how this works right you
could have that and that by the way
that that used to be u.s policy going
back democrats republicans that was not
a partisan issue that was
we yeah yeah we are going to pay
attention to what's going on in our
backyard
because it is in our national strategic
interests to do so right because that
actually matters that's why guantanamo
bay
is our oldest overseas um institution
overseas military installation
that we have since 1898 and i've
actually walked those trails
uh the rough riders went in um a lot of
that base
you know you can actually see you know
kind of walk through the battles that
took place
during the smash american war it's kind
of amazing just to be able to walk in
those footsteps
but you know for him to not just stand
up
for being the leader of the united
states and
act like a great power right it really
goes to show you
that how much that you know it's it's
almost like the you know
biden's personal decline almost
parallels the way that he's putting
america
on the path to decline you know this
this here's here's the analogy i use
it's like uh
the dad who gets bossed around at work
and is
feeble so we go home he goes home angry
and beats his wife because she can't do
anything about it right
not strong enough to stand up to those
who are actually causing us problems
the biden administration has a really
easy time of condemning its own citizens
the p 75 million people voted for trump
they're the bad guys
but russia china and iran oh better
better better
uh you know right they were right if you
were if you were walking around
the wrong place at the capitol at the
wrong time and you know i say this is
somebody who was was physically there on
constitution avenue watching as
as this all took place right you know i
knew and i said this on air on one
american news at the time i said there
are going to be people showing up
a quarter of the way back or a third of
the way back there no
idea they're just going to walk up and
see an open door and say oh i guess
i guess this is open i i guess they're
like or someone's holding the door open
yeah
holding it open i guess i can just walk
in right you can be held
without charge you can be ha and and by
the way held
for for peacefully and it's essentially
trespassing whatever he's doing right
right none of the no the rhetoric
actually matches
in many cases with the charges that are
being that are going on but you'll be
held without bail
which is a complete gross violation the
constitution you can be you can have
your you can be fired from work you can
have your your personal funds
and your banking your d-bank all that
stuff's going on entire family in texas
was just arrested and i was looking
through the charges there's not even
a including a minor a minor member of
the family was arrested
no violent acts whatsoever so that's joe
biden when it comes to
his own citizens right his own
constituents and so
we have a really interesting situation
right now where it almost feels like
he doesn't treat those people as if they
are citizens of the united states and he
is their president
right it's almost like he kind of thinks
well those guys are trump supporters
so i can treat them differently than i
would treat a regular u.s citizen who's
all of us this is what people
need to understand in this country joe
biden has not been speaking to you this
entire time
that's what's really fascinating you get
these conservatives who are like oh i
can't believe joe biden said that it's
crazy it's like bro he's not talking to
you
when joe biden came out was like we
might need another lockdown in this
country
taxes in florida had already reopened he
wasn't talking to you red states
when he comes out and says all these
things he is not talking to you he's
talking about
you they don't like you they hate you
and republicans conservatives
disaffected liberals political homeless
idw whatever you are you better
recognize that they look at themselves
as the the correct the mainstream the
appropriate
and anyone who deviates from that group
is an outside other extremist
so you could be i mean this is really
what cultivates authoritarianism is made
of
i have a great example of this um and
it's not biden and this this is why what
makes it so perfect
it was um lina when um who
is that
so she's the she's um a cnn i think she
just put her own medical
medical analyst right she's actually the
former president of planned parenthood
they never
mention that right but she has this
comment and it's so illustrative
of this mentality and it so perfectly uh
defines what you're talking about
because she says you know
we need to make life harder for the
unvaccinated we need to
uh make there be penalties for for them
going through this
we need to and and i'm not even talking
about necessarily focusing on on her
vaccine comments but
and which of course a lot of people
talked about they've gone over and up
but
when she says we who is she talking
about
when she says we need to do this you're
not you're not a member of government
you're not elected to anything you're
you're a cnn contributor
and yet you're acting as if you have
state-like
power over and that is why i use this
term that i've
started to put it into uh the colloquial
parlance and eventually
i call it the overstate right and this
it it sort of
combines this idea of the sovereignty
of the the us government right and state
governments
but also the connection with the media
with academia
with um social media et cetera silicon
valley wall street
this idea that there is so when she's
saying we like what are you talking
about the party
right the party right again party
members that will allow
yourself to be brainwashed in the moment
who's who's the the
american shadow communist party we'll
call it that we is a very powerful word
and that it's a cult building mechanism
yeah and i and i noticed that nobody is
bringing up the fact that she just keeps
using it over and over we need to do
this we need to set these in place no we
need to have these
when uh why are you saying we right and
it's also otherizing because it's we
versus you right it's us versus them
when i listened
when i see the things that joe biden is
posting let me see if i can uh pull up
something specific
there's a video i tweeted here we go
biden said actually i'm gonna play it
i'm just gonna play the video
is it not working we can't oh i muted it
that's the problem
i'm like why is there no sound coming
out oh i turned the sound off we do a
little technology
here we go you ready it's no longer just
about who gets to vote
or making it easier for eligible voters
to vote
it's about who gets to count the vote
who gets to count whether or not your
vote counted at all
it's about so there's that's only 16
seconds i don't know the full context
but assuming that is uh close enough to
the context
you know he's talking about voting laws
in georgia new laws right
new laws uh this country is already in
divorce
i mean seriously when that woman on cnn
says we
need to do x she's not she's not calling
you
we she's not referring to you the people
who are watching the show
she's saying you're outside this when
joe biden says it's no longer about who
gets to vote
it's about who gets to count the vote or
some of that effect he's basically
saying it doesn't matter
what is he talking about where's the
context of that
they're claiming republicans are trying
to strip away the right to vote when in
actuality it's the democrats who are
doing it
okay and so he's saying it's not just
about
paraphrasing well i you know i guess
that's why who gets to count it because
he's
arguing that the republicans will count
it incorrectly can i just say though
i and i got to say this i got to be
clear we're going to do a little fact
checking around here
thank you jack as i was driving up here
and you know we're not going to docks
but we are in is somewhat rural area
i did not see a single fedex kinkos
on my entire drive here and kamala
harris yeah
gotta say i think she's right on this
one no kinkos even though they went out
of business 15 years ago not a single
kinkos
did i she said kinko's she actually said
can't go out of business for 15 years
yeah well they were it's fed up yeah so
fedex bought them out but even still
like she said
kinko's that's like that's kitty city
we've had
a lot of people talk about peaceful
divorce in this country
and i'm not a fan because i don't want
to see china take over like we need
american unity american culture we need
to have strong come back but a lot of
people have said
let me peaceful divorce let me ask you a
question yeah how many presidents do we
have right now
how many presidents of the united states
do we have right now i don't know what
you mean by that
like obviously we have one we have joe
biden right we have joe biden but
do you think that there are people who
at this point just see him so
illegitimate that they just don't view
him as the president
they would view but this is not this is
not biden or trump
this is 2016. when people said trump is
not my president
right you that's exactly where it
started where
there were russians have millions and
you can go by the way
joe biden he gives he you have the clip
he said there but there was another clip
where he said
you know this is not what that's not how
we do things in america
you win you lose and then you go on
you don't you don't keep whining about
it and then i'm like joe i'd take two
seconds
and run a twitter search on his own
account and he says
uh the the 2016 election was interfered
with by russia they've undermined our
democracy
right right right right right right
right
right
right
right
right
right right right right he said it right
begin referring to themselves as we
which excludes you
you need to recognize what that means is
happening in this country
already it is very obvious that there
are two clearly distinct groups
one currently has the power of federal
law enforcement and they are using it to
crush dissidents like little old ladies
there's that video where the cop opens
the door for the little old lady
arrested charged
some of these people in solitary antifa
free to go
it's very obvious where we're at right
now when joe biden comes out
and he says like they're basically
saying repeatedly
we not us and the we as a reference to
democrats and the party members and not
anybody who who opposes them or any
americans
he is not a president for this country
he is a president for a faction
you can use the word we uh for everybody
like i think we need
decentralized free software social media
and i'm not talking about a group of us
of course of course but when she said we
need to make life hard for the people
who aren't vaccinated
in in her context she's referring to we
as a select group of people how they are
going to
control and punish punch she
specifically is talking about
punitive measures yeah for and not even
to get into that issue
but punitive measures for people who
have decided not to opt into
your preferred preference we are going
to take puny again
it's not even that if you decide against
them there are people who are
pro-vaccine
who have danced and sang at the at the
at the uh uh
advent of mrna vaccines who are told by
their doctors
for pregnancy reasons for allergy
reasons you are not recommended to get
this
and they're saying make their lives
harder because we're hearing autoimmune
disease that that
apparently some people have uh this fda
announcement
that's right that's why i i'm i'm so uh
some of the people
by like door-to-door vaccination because
you gotta you have it like you go to a
doctor they give you a list you check
off
do you have all they give you a huge
list of ailments and they're like check
out right
right because the doctor looks at and
goes oh man we can't prescribe you this
antibiotic because you have x
syndrome but a guy going to your
doorstep they're not going through this
at 7 11 at bars i don't want to get in
that whole debate the point is
they're not talking about when she said
we she was referring to
a group of people who are
ex-governmental or are
extra governmental who somehow have the
ability to implement policies
and and and enforcement over everybody
else
who is she or the people on cnn to
assert that they have the ability
to even enforce non-laws over people
who are not part of that here's the
essential truth they do have that power
right they do they know it they know
they do and they and when she says that
and doesn't get any pushback by from any
and you can see there's three people
on at that point no push back whatsoever
because they all have that power
because they know they're in the
driver's seat and they know that they
are part of
and there isn't a name for it and that's
why i'm i'm coming up with an i'm
overseeing this title
the overstate because they know that
they are a part
of that influence network right of those
competing interests of these
in many cases cnn's owned by a
multi-multinational company
right so we know that they are part of
that group
that is in power and they know that they
can wield that power
over others and in this moment there's
no check
there's no check on that power
republicans aren't even involved in the
culture war
what was it jesse kelly i think said
republicans law democrats won the
culture war because they were
they were the only ones fighting it so
this is this is um
you know i know i'm not supposed to do
this but this is uh william buckley
you know this is the problem with his
famous phrase so his famous phrase was
uh a conservative is someone who stands
a thwart history yelling stop
right well if you're just someone who's
standing at thwart history yelling stop
and yet other people are going to say
hey let's try this let's go here
was he insulting conservatives no that
was his that i mean that is like his i'm
this is like his most famous yeah quote
that's attributed to him
who wouldn't want to be a conservative
right you know and
it's he's not actually now if you are a
conservative you can say well oh i see
what he's saying we need to preserve
institutions that
and social norms and and culture and
morality that have
sustained us for all these years et
cetera et cetera but
if that's your tactic to just sit there
and say stop
we're not going to do any of this
anymore it's like
no one's going to come to your party no
but nobody's going to show up
he's right you're not offering anyone
anything that he has right that's
exactly what can serve him
and always follow that for 70 years but
but
no he but he's identified the group they
didn't adhere to what he said
he identified a group of people that
just said uh we're good here
and that's it they're not fighting so
i don't know it's standing so you right
you just stand there and say stop dude i
actually ryan with this little bow tie
i think there's a lot of things in this
country that need to change but i think
there's a lot of things that that are
good we want to keep the good
you it's imagine imagine you know what
these these communists are
the the overstate these the party
members they represent a group that says
we got this amazing skyscraper let's
tear the whole thing down and then live
amongst the rubble as we rebuild
then you have conservatives who are like
the building's fine as it is stopped and
then you've got other people who are
saying
we can probably improve this building
quite a bit let's keep it
and get rid of the broken parts and put
in goodbyes i like those people that
that's awesome that makes the most sense
so yeah i don't identify with those who
are like this this is my problem with
with um the way that a lot of people
have been going
against the crt debate the critical race
theory debate which and don't get me
wrong i think people are doing fantastic
work chris ruppo uh specifically on that
front but
if you're just going to be one of these
governors who says i'm banning critical
race theory and critical race theory bad
like okay but
if you ever come out of power they can
just take that away right
you need to be explaining to people
the alternative you need to be
explaining to people
what is number one true history but then
also
why right why are these things
considered good and this is considered
bad you can't just
say to people oh we're going to ban this
and this this is out then
i think that's why i think conservative
is probably the wrong word
some populist maybe is a better word for
it you know when we had charlie kirk on
the show he mentioned that during occupy
the conservative movement wasn't ready
for a lot of these things
like calling out the corporations and
censorship and wall street and big tech
and things like that
and i'm like i don't think conservatives
ever are because they're literally
always just saying stop
reactionary is that what those
reactionaries are uh yeah reactionaries
oppose the revolution
right so reactionary is a term that came
up during the french revolution and so
it was actually
a propaganda term used by the the
jacobins
and the the murderous authoritarians of
the french revolution
who to for their political opponents who
said hey maybe we
shouldn't kill everybody and destroy all
the french culture you know maybe we can
just start go around
executing people because we decided we
want to um they were
they were called reactionary so this was
actually a propaganda term
used by the red terror right right right
so
uh for back to the conservative
statement the populist is maybe a better
word
the libertarians are very much involved
but they don't like donald trump i think
with
like uh dave smith and the mises caucus
you actually have strong principled
libertarians now who very much so will
say they don't like donald trump
but very much so will oppose a lot of
what the democrats are doing
and i think that's something a lot of
the populists actually agree with so
they might not agree
with criticism of trump but i think the
one thing that trump
animated or the one thing about trump
that animated a lot of people was
anti-establishment
i think there's substantially more
anti-establishment people
in whatever this faction is so i don't
know what the right word is to describe
them
the people who are actually demanding
things you look at people like you know
lauren bobert or marjory taylor green
who actually say hey we want a thing
most republicans are like we're gonna
we say no to democrats i'm like what are
you for what are you actually advocating
for
okay i'm smiling right now because you
you mentioned those and i want everyone
to know that i didn't say
anything to tim prior to this show
you mentioned those two names just
because you see these two people who are
fighting right you look in the news and
they're actively fighting four things
when i said that there were potentially
members of congress
that were on the joe biden list
it was exactly those two marjorie taylor
green and laura
i i just just those two like here's our
list it's two
so far i mean again i don't know if if
this is the final list but
there's the two members of congress that
i was told you know what they've done
you know what you know what big tech has
done by banning
people on the right they have made sure
that the only voices you hear
are the for the most part spineless
weak republicans who just say please
stop democrats
the fierce fighting angry people who are
like this is what we want and why we
want it all have been banned
not all but mostly so now what they've
done is well they're banned or atomized
what do you mean what do you mean by
atomizer so atomize is a great example
for
uh you know margery teller green right
yes it's like right you know you we've
we've isolated you we've broken you down
to your constituent atoms where you're
you're not a republican right and they
force her to go through these struggle
sessions
and even the republicans right and
that's what i say like even mccarthy
is kind of saying well i'm going to
strip her off her committees but i'm not
going to kick her out of the caucus and
all that like so he's going along with
it
they want to control he goes along with
this so this is this atomization of
it's and it's it's part of an other
rising um this goes back to
you know it actually goes back to uh
what the german stasi would do
in in east germany because when they
realized that it got to a certain point
where they were disappearing too many
people and
they realized that okay you know this is
getting a little bit too untenuous for
us
well okay what we're going to do then is
instead of of
you know disappearing you and locking
you up because that's hard it costs
money right you need to go through trial
etc
we're just going to destroy your
reputation right we're just going to
destroy what people think of you we're
going to smear you
we're going to attack you we're going to
use all of our power implements
so that people yeah you can be out there
and you can have your quote unquote free
speech
but no one will listen to you yeah they
they
amazingly condemn marjory taylor green
for things she said before she was even
in office
right kevin mccarthy goes along with
everything the democrats say and it's
very obvious the established republicans
and the democrats are part of the
uniparty and right now the republicans
are just frantic because there is an
invasive force of populists who have
come in and started making changes so
maybe
what will happen is uh they'll put that
they'll put out that list oh lauren
bobert and marjory taylor green are on
that list huh
i'd imagine the america first candidates
the right-wing populist candidates
obviously huge overlap the ones who are
trying to primary they're all going to
be labeled extremists
there's going to be stories in every
major newspaper about oh these
republicans they're they're evil and
dangerous we can't let them win
by the way i i don't know if anyone saw
this but this is this is a huge
problem that the populists have right
liz cheney right liz cheney who is sort
of the
the avatar of sort of the anti-populace
she's the avatar of the establishment
winger she's
been propped up as this she just raised
1.8 million
right she actually put up the highest
numbers for any house member
right that's liz cheney now i'd like to
go through that 1.8 million yeah where
did you get exactly
where's all that coming from well the
squad members raised most of their money
outside their districts squadrons
this is going to come down
to a money fight and there are extremely
powerful interests
that are fighting against this and so i
i do believe by the way that populists
have the upper hand in terms of numbers
right now i do
i really do but the money side is going
to get filtered in they've broken
the working class oh sure you might have
the working
class on your side a million grassroots
donors who are too broke now because the
economy's been destroyed
to actually give you a penny to help
your campaign yeah when uh the roman
empire fell apart completely the middle
class eviscerated and evaporated it was
gone
they completely disseminated the you
working you've got
these elites worth the the the net worth
of the billionaires went up
substantially
the major corporations stock value
started to skyrocket
small businesses destroyed and what did
that help do
destroy grassroots activism
bernie sanders famously had an average
donation of 23
or whatever that night and once again
asking but he was but bernie was able to
to rise up because he had the people on
his side and all of that money flowing
into him empowered him greatly
well be it fortuitous for the
establishment that they have destroyed
the economy and hurt the working class
and made them mostly destitute and
homeless
and living off of government welfare and
unemployment bills and child tax credits
now you could have 10 million supporters
if they're too
broke to donate to you they don't but
the wealthy elites whose net worth went
up
they can donate whatever they want to
whoever they want super pacs so we went
to the
um you know you mentioned you mentioned
the workers right
we were out in nevada for the ufc fight
um
we went to joe rogan and dave chappelle
the night before and then because
rogan's in town because he does
commentary so we go to mcgregor and
poirier
and at the stadiums where we're going at
the arenas where we were going to show
up
the concession stand the line was like
40 minutes long
for each of them why you would go up and
you see there's only two people working
behind the stand there
wow wow that's it right because that
town that city was which is that's
that's the entertainment capital of of
the state right that's that's their
entire economy
it was decimated by kovid and then now
they have a worker shortage because
there's so many people
that are living off government and say
hey i get this money for free
for that i got to go deal with drunk
people i got to go deal with you know
whatever he got my order wrong so i got
to go deal with emotional abuse
why go back to work if i'm if i can
still get down for money for this it's a
massive
worker shortage out there it's a time
bomb you know
it's uh the bill will come do
they're the it's it's which law of
thermodynamics
ian you know perhaps the second law of
thermodynamics second law
to be honest i don't know are you
talking about uh when an object in
motion will remain in motion
forced upon uh this idea that you can
get things for free without making
things
oh free energy yeah eventually what
happens is there
the value of the dollar becomes zero
because
why work well the problem with the
thermodynamic thing that says you can't
get more energy out of the system than
you put into it
only assumes that there's a closed
system that you're working with them but
in reality there are no closed systems
energy can always come from further away
than we knew it existed so
i do believe zero opponents mean like
slave labor in china yeah like there
will always be more slaves we can always
have more children to make them more
slaves that i've kind of been joking
americans spending money and not
producing anything won't last we'll have
to default on it that we're going to
have to default on the phone right
and by the way this this this all goes
back to the 90s
this goes back to nafta this goes back
to china and the wt
it goes back to 79. this goes back it
goes back and back and back this was the
idea
china will be the manufacturing base
right that will be china that will be
moved to china right and then america
will be
the consumers america will say you sit
there
you're going to you know what whatever
is the new movie that gets rolled off
the island of the line you're all going
to go watch it
then and now they don't even need to do
that now you're just streaming right you
can just sit in your home
and you're going to have it delivered to
you and you click this and you say oh
i'm going to watch this
and then and then you just go on to the
next one and you go on to the next one
it's the end of days my friends
check out this story from the daily mail
1972 prediction of the collapse of
society
is on track to happen by 2040. economic
growth will halt in
in a decade food will become scarce and
human population will decline
kpmg study finds they say mit used a
world simulation model to learn how a
world would fare from 1972 to 2016.
the model looked at a number of factors
such as population
industrial output and persistent
pollution and found a societal collapse
could happen by 2040.
the research was criticized at the time
but an accounting firm analysis
took another look at mit's data and
found their stark prediction was correct
the recent work shows our business as
usual mentality will spark a decline of
economic growth
within the next decade but a total
collapse by 2040.
i wonder if there are powerful uh
international elites
who saw that news in 1972 saw those
stories
and then not by a conspiracy but by a
stand-alone complex
very powerful individuals influenced by
similar things decided to take actions
within their industries in a certain
direction which led us to today
oh like a self-fulfilling prophecy i
yeah i got one i can go back even
further
what do you got nikola tesla what did he
say
1920s and it's just very quick very
quick
technical advances are inevitably
driving us toward
the grossest kind of materialism before
long
the social system of be life will be
universal
be life bug men bug men so we've got
we've got
predicted by tesla we've got cuba and
revolt maybe it's nothing maybe it's a
one-off we got south africa
there was some audio that was posted by
the guy phoenix ammunition guys tweeted
this out retweeted it
where it's like audio recordings where
he's like we're we're lending out
a thousand rounds they're saying they're
running out of ammunition and then and
then
there's another audio recording where
it's like we're we're running out of
bullets there's thousands of them we
can't stop them by nightfall the city
will burn
south of the africa dude when you look
at these things you see
jacob zuma's son by the way oh yeah yeah
yeah
responsibility responsibly so his father
was the president who was arrested right
right right
responsibly we've got war with china
potentially we've got russia china iran
threatening us over what's happening in
cuba
we had that incident a couple years ago
was that in venezuela where that cruise
ship was like rammed or something
oh yeah the venezuelan tried to steal it
you get this mit report
and we're sitting here talking about
civil war and thucydides trap
and the fourth turning and now we can
add
another projector to that you know
humans blowing each other up
is one problem and i don't want to
derail this because it's a good
conversation but what i fear is what
happened in texas when it froze over
and the wind turbines stopped working
the electric grid shut down
the centralized electric grid failed
people started freezing to death
wildfires that burn people alive because
they can't get out
uh asteroid impacts collisions floods
we have a centralized electric grid that
cannot handle these things
people without electricity i i've never
seen that in my life and i don't want to
but that is what that's what i'm afraid
of this this stuff blowing each other up
this has been a threat since
no no the dawn of this man 194 this
20-40 studies that say we're going to
blow up but it's gonna saying society is
going to collapse
yeah well what is society how are they
defining that's why
i you know one of the first things i
ever did when i got a smartphone was i
downloaded a survival guide
yeah i did too i have one on my phone
yeah because it's just a smart things to
do people go camping sometimes yeah if
you have a smartphone get one
i'm like you know i might go camping i
need to know how to start a fire or you
know like
watch out for poison ivy or something
but hey in the event that you get lost
in the woods you're gonna love that you
got a little bit of that battery left
you turn the brightness weight down and
start looking like what do i do how do i
find my way out
you know what's really interesting one
of the biggest mistakes people make when
they get lost somewhere
is they leave their car you know why
that's the stupidest thing you can do
when they look yeah when the
helicopter's flying over like there's a
car and they're like a million reasons
that's the worst thing you could do they
go down they find the car and the
person's going or
or double back to it i mean that would
be just stay in the car you're trying to
find it
i'm not gonna give you advice i'm gonna
say just take care of yourself be
responsible
yeah you look at what happened in texas
there's things like that that happen but
here's the crazy part
our cities have gotten so big what
happens when the power goes out for a
long enough period of time that
order breaks down i mean you look at
what happened in south africa
with all of the stores being looted the
west is being looted when order is just
when people are like hey guess what law
is off the purge happens well so and not
only that but not
not it's not just order it's when made
to order right it's when on demand right
breaks down
right it's when i can't get my disney
plus it's i can't get my streaming i
can't get this i can't get my uber eats
i can't get all of these different
things where stuff is just delivered to
me by my gig slaves
it's um that when that breaks down and
suddenly i have to i don't people just
shop anymore it's easy easily
exemplified by the uh treehouse of
horror with the simpsons where it was a
play on the shining
and homer was uh trying to you know had
no tv
so he became he became murderous and
started rampaging around trying to kill
his family the simpson family
and then finally they're no tv
and then they're outside and then homer
is like come sit with me by the warmth
of the tv
and he finally has a little tv and then
they're sitting there and the tv power
dies and they're frozen and then homer
says urge to rise
or urge to kill rising urge to kill
rising
that's basically what it is you're
referring to the crazy thing about this
is
it used to be that if you wanted a
cheeseburger you had to wait for it you
had to go buy the ingredients
you had to go make it yourself then
we're in the in the diner era
and then mcdonald's is like we're an
inventor way where you can walk up and
get that burger real quick and people
were like whoa
now people are so spoiled they go to a
restaurant they wait five minutes they
freak out where's my phone
they're throwing stuff at the counter
yeah if we go back to the era where it's
like you gotta wait a month to get
tomatoes
because you're growing so this is this
is you know having my um
you know my wife and then her parents
live with us and they're from eastern
europe right
they don't have that they don't have
that at all because they don't have
it maybe some of like the big cities in
in uh in eastern europe they have that
but
and for there for them it's hey i i went
out in the morning i bought some fresh
stuff and now i'm going to cook it
i'm going to spend the day you know
washing it and cooking it and preparing
the dinner and getting it done and
that's
that i mean uh you know i joke about
this but they won't even
use the the dishwasher they just why
would i use that
i can just wash it by hand well to be
honest dishwashers don't work yeah they
don't you end up having to wash it
anyway right
right but i mean they won't if they
wouldn't even consider to putting it in
the dishwasher right
you know and it's it's really is and
sometimes we do have this kind of
culture clash
um they're not big on air conditioning
um
yeah and they're super they're just
super like
they're way more used to hey if you want
to get something if you want some
walnuts if you want some cucumbers hey
go outside
here's a basket go get them yeah right
you want some cranberries go do this
that's how you take care of it that's
the future not the best and
the future and you look at what we have
now and it always makes me kind of
reflect back
on the way you know strawberries in
winter you know you come out and say
is this better right is is our way
better
it's stronger varies in winter it's
better for building brain matter
because like having access to all those
nutrients make us
able to be stronger potentially
intelligently but
people have been abusing it i mean if
you could ask i've been walking around
i partially disagree it's the aspartame
i think i partially disagree and i think
you're correct about the availability of
nutrients
but people eat random trash yeah that's
the problem they
are abusing the system they're not
taking advantage of it right properly
they're taking a disadvantage
with it they go to mcdonald's they buy a
cheeseburger and fries what do they have
for dinner
do chicken sandwich and fries and it's
like you're not getting real vegetables
you might get a tomato i guess but
that's that's which is the fruit tanya's
uh uh
uh father when when he came to the us um
we went out i think we
i forget where we were but we were in
like some place and like the only thing
that was open was fast food
and we got some stuff and he was like
i'm not eating this like this emmy like
why
he's like this is not food this is like
plastic yeah mush
and then so when i go over and visit by
the way and you eat the food there like
farm to table isn't like they don't even
say that because
that's just food right right in eastern
europe so you get it and then you start
eating stuff
and you realize it doesn't have this
sort of sensationalism kind of tastes
that u.s food would have but it's richer
and you can really taste you can
really taste you know the true nutrients
that are in it
you can taste so many different flavors
that you weren't used to
having say oh this is what meat is
supposed to taste like this is what
vegetables are supposed to it's not just
that it's it's when you're eating
nothing but garbage
you you lose well i'll put a better way
when you're really really hungry
everything tastes better
when you're eating healthy and then you
have those garden fresh veggies and
you're eating it you're like it just
tastes
so good it's like when you imagine like
chugging
a bunch of soda and then eating a scoop
of ice cream and like the sweet your
sweetness overload you ever have that
yeah the ice cream doesn't even taste
sweet because you have too much sugar in
your mouth already
yeah that's basically everything i was
reading about sugar addiction
and how the sugar content of our drinks
kept going up for a long period of time
because people would drink a soda with
like 10 grams of sugar
and then they would find a soda with 15
a bit oh this one's better
and so the next company's like make it
17 make it 19. make it 20 25.
now it's up to i think for like a coke
48 grams of sugar
isn't that the thing where and i and i'm
sure this is more of a more apocryphal
than actual true story but
the idea that coca-cola used to be you
know it was used to actually have
cocaine in it right so that was really
good the name
so um i think that's true you know no no
no no no no
no that's true the the next part is you
know we're basically they said well once
that was
um once that was criminalized they had
to find something else that was just as
addictive to put in their sodas so they
found sugar well it's not caffeine
caffeine has a has has a very very
similar effect on the human body to
cocaine
oh wow they did oh well sugar energy
boost yeah
oh yeah well i mean caffeine causes
euphoria it's it's
it like it stimulates the brain in a
very very similar way
there actually is and i think we talked
about this on one of the last times i
was here but
um that you could actually talk you
could actually trace the enlightenment
to the introduction of coffee in europe
psychoactive stimulants and that's why
people are suddenly right and then prior
to that
right and if you look at any like
medieval literature here or any medieval
just sources you always see people
always they're going to the inn they're
drinking mead they're drinking that's
like
people are kind of buzzed all the time
like they'd water you know
healthy water or drinkable water was not
of readily available
in the middle ages and so if you want
something you want you want it fermented
you want something that's been processed
so you are going to be drinking alcohol
more so there's this idea that people
just in the middle ages were just
generally kind of buzzed it was it was
it was safer to drink you know
right did uh did you know that coke has
coffee yeah they do
and i did not i just found this out
today really it was really it was a
coca-cola can but it had coffee on it
and i was confused
and i was like i'm gonna try it it's got
splenda in it so i i cracked it open i
taste i was like wow
it's actually really good yeah i thought
it was gonna be bad and then i was like
i looked at the i looked at the pepsi
coffee they had pepsi pepsi
pepsi kona i i looked at the nutrition
information on the coke and it was like
11 grams of sugar and i was like that's
impossible this is way too sweet and
boom splenda
splendid i don't drink that stuff what
do you use stevia uh
stevia is all right but i just either
drink water or i drink pure sugar
you sugar whatever splenda's sucralose
which is i don't know
sucralose yeah it's a it's a it's uh
your body doesn't digest it i'm not a
fan of that stuff i like
monkey fruit we've been doing a lot of
things it's legit what's that plus
blender was astro training no splenda
this is saying that it's super low it is
splenda okay are they original i'm not i
don't care if any of that's enough
maybe that's equal oh this says that
they originally were contains sucralose
uh it's also known for using monk fruit
stevia and allulose
yeah monkey right here is all right um
equal is aspartame
and then sweet and low is saccharine
yeah i don't care if any of that stuff
you know we have a bunch of sodas from
this company called route 66
route 66 i just ordered from it's like a
chicago company pure cane sugar
i don't i don't want to have too much of
that anyway but if we're gonna have some
pure change we do have these japanese
sodas that are really fun it's got the
marble and you like pop it in
yeah and that's fructose glucose syrup
which probably just means high fructose
corn syrup so
and we got a bunch of sodas with that
high fructose corn syrup
what's the new stuff uh something
fructose there's a new kind of fructose
that's out there
that's the other thing by the way with
tonya she she anything that's like
sodas anything carbonated all that she
just doesn't want any of it water it's
great
just amazing she's like i want she
drinks water and if she wants a little
bit of a pick-me-up
she'll go for a green tea i went out to
uh we got pizza today
and they didn't have water i was like i
guess i'll have coke wow i don't like
coke at all
yeah that's some middle ages stuff i
mean they could pour me a glass of water
but i don't want to drink
some big unfiltered well water you know
what i mean i'm big on coconut water
this is the moho
we've been getting and this is like no
other coconut water i've ever had i mean
it's just enough sugar
it's ph balanced for your body ph
balance i heard that they used to use uh
coconut water as iv fluid yeah
like you could i don't know if it's true
yeah sounds cool though
i got when i was in when i was living in
china um coconut milk i
really got yazer at night um i was like
yeah um anywhere i could get it uh or
and it's big over there it's actually
pretty big i was drinking coconut milk
like crazy there was actually this
taiwanese brand that i just got really
into
so what's the future man are we all
gonna be back to living in huts and
caves and um that's what happened when
atlantis got smashed
twelve thousand eight hundred years ago
historically uh what
comet's shattered okay okay okay i don't
want to talk about atlantis
you guys are short term this is before
it went under antarctica let's talk
about what happened yes
let's keep it okay good idea political
appeal what happened to what happened to
the people
so so look so so i mean italy still
exists
right i mean it is probably still like
like rome as a city still exists right
the roman
it got a nile in terms of the people it
got conquered and then reconquered and
then conquered back and then reconquered
right
right yes people were living in like
shelled out buildings and and the
population was decimated by 90 plus
and so and so when you put all this
together right when you do put all this
together
when you talk about the the weakening
of the u.s as a system right the u.s as
a system
and then you go to the military side and
you can see
so russia iran and china are telling us
what we need to do in our backyard
and then you've got the u.s navy study
that comes out that says
look we would lose a major conflict
right now on the seas we would lose it
just straight i say there's a former
naval officer and i think they're right
like we are not ready to fight
a near pure competitor right um you know
if imagine the u.s losing and i'll just
put it out there imagine the u.s losing
a maritime conflict over taiwan
like china moves on taiwan we say we're
going to defend them we say
no we japan comes to you know rallies
um but korea says you know not worth it
maybe
and then uh australia says you know
we'll we'll pitch in
um but really you you know the us is
leading the whole thing and they just
straight up lose
if that happens think about what that
does to american
to the american psyche not just the
american decisive decision
what happens when right when
when the united states has blood in the
water and all the sharks start coming
realizing the us can't defend its allies
anymore
all it takes when you look at what
happens in a lot of these countries like
the police breakdown in south africa
where the cops are actually looting now
once the unrest gets to a certain point
people say
the cops can't stop us and we saw in the
united states in baltimore and ferguson
the police can stop you know it's like
whack-a-mole when the whack-a-mole is
coming up really slow the cops can go
and stop
unrest but when they keep coming up like
crazy there's not enough when i was in
so i was in the freddie gray riots um
not participating
um but um the thing that got me about
that was the speed
right the speed at which the whole city
just i was driving down the street
and i saw some random people walking the
street just stop
and throw something through a weight you
know climb in the rob from the store and
what
blew my mind was that you knew it was
going to happen
everyone in the city knew there's going
to be riots tonight
it'll probably be around 5 5 30 and the
police were basically told
so the governor hadn't called in uh the
national guard yet actually a buddy who
was called up in that
but for the first night there was no
national guard right
um you had the mayor stephanie
rawlings-blake who says we need to give
them room to protest
uh marilyn mosby gives this he heard no
justice no peace
uh speech blocks me on twitter for
yelling about her
um completely illegal but i'm actually
glad that uh that she blocked the okay
boomer girl uh blocked me today actually
congratulations oh thank you i just said
thank god thank god just uh
uh wasn't she doing like a promo for a
phone or something so she was doing a
promo for a phone
yeah and then someone said to her like
oh are you gonna do an ios version and
then she responds
team android right and then on the tweet
because it says like how what you know
what format
it said tweet by iphone on the tweet
so i just quote tweeted that and i wrote
tweet by iphone didn't you block me
period
so anyway so so the right so everyone
knows that it's going to happen the
police are basically only deployed
around certain areas they've they've
made lines
but if you happen if you're at the
medauman mall which is in north
baltimore
that place was smashed apart and i'll
say this too because people will get on
me and say oh well that was
you know this whatever it was every
every race every ethnicity every group
under the sun you saw asians hispanic
white blac
everybody was getting in on this right
you were going to the target you were
grabbing a tv you were grabbing anything
you could get
with their pickup trucks full of
appliances that p and i would just see
them just driving by
with it or a guy like holding a couple
of laptop boxes walking down the street
um i mean it was just chaos just mass
chaos
it and it was in a in an eye blink
everything
that you think our society is
right all of those basic you know
unspoken
into the unspoken rules but then also
just the actual laws on the books
disappeared and everybody knew it and
everybody it was like a purge night it
was the only difference between i think
the first purge movie had been out at
that point
you know the only difference was that in
the purge they actually have an
announcement
this was just sort of a tacit
understanding that hey you you know so
do crimes now here's what happens if
china takes taiwan and the u.s can't
stop it
that's when the rest of the world sees
the united states cannot police anything
they can't defend their allies and then
you'll start think seeing things pop up
in certain areas the u.s will try to
quell certain uprisings
allies will call for help the u.s won't
be able to and then there it is the
taiwan thing hong kong thing makes me
kind of think of cuba like i don't think
the u.s should be involved with taiwan
and hong kong purely because it's china
geographically right next to china
whereas i don't think they should be
missing cuba whereas
not that it's it's american soil and not
that taiwan is chinese soil
and if the americans were to invade cuba
and and take it they would do it
economically anyway
yeah fascinating that china has to its
southeast this island that they claim is
theirs
and the people there are not communists
and the u.s is saying don't you dare
intervene or we'll stop you and then you
have in the southeast of the us
cuba which is communist and you get
china russian iran saying don't you dare
intervene
which and by the way it's interesting
enough that one thing that people leave
out about the taiwan situation the
reason they don't call themselves the
country of taiwan officially
is because they still maintain that they
are the sovereign power over
all of china and mongolia oh of course
of course
so that's republican what's going on
mainland china is actually west taiwan
that's right right exactly so they the
government the
republic of china fled to taiwan this is
like in the 60s
right so they've never officially
recognized
the communist government of china as the
official government the u.s did under
jimmy carter
this was not something that that
kissinger said they were never going to
do
that nixon said never do this but carter
gave official recognition
this is what switched the seat by the
way so the republic of time this is
actually
uh it's it's not just an academic thing
because prior to the 1970s
the seat on the u.n security council for
china
was actually controlled by taiwan
because that was seen as the
internationally recognized government of
china
when that switch happened again 1979
right when that switch happened
that is when you really now see and then
10 years later is what tiananmen square
and what was what repercussion did china
face what repercussions did the ccp
face for the tiananmen square
massachusetts i think anything
i mean did they anything any any
sanctions rewarded
they were rewarded with increased
foreign domestic
uh investment they were said a direct
investment they said they were told
we're gonna we just need to bring them
more into the order
they just need more kfc's and more
mcdonald's and saks fifth avenue and
gucci and louboutin and everything else
if you can just get them more of the
international order
well they'll just be better okay this is
by design this is it has nothing to do
with human rights it has nothing to do
with human agency it has nothing to do
with
all of these things natural law all of
these things we talk it's money
it's money and power at the end of the
day all these fancy
you know terms and euphemisms that we
can come up with it's it's just money
and power at the end of the day
they have it and they don't want you to
have it and the idea is that uh
you the pleb will be in the uh renter
class and they will own is it they don't
want you the
the pleb to have it because they're
afraid the pleb will unseat them
like are they afraid of their are they
afraid for their lives and their family
and their money okay you need to
understand
yes as the ignorant rabble you truly
don't understand worldly affairs
okay and uh the elite i don't understand
need to manage all of this stuff
otherwise
humans simply become massively
overweight
and addicted to drugs and video games
and they over populate and eventually
the earth just falls apart
it is incumbent upon better men to
decide what
you should do with your life referred to
as no blessing
don't worry you will own nothing but you
will be
happy my question though is will i learn
discipline
it won't matter i see why because you
won't always be able
to disrupt anything but do these people
have discipline i'm i don't
of course they don't whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa you can't impose discipline
on our bettors they are the highborn and
we are the locals
and that's where this is no i go back
look people there's there's some guy
who's getting on me for
running a game of thrones blog and
that's like how i first you know kind of
was operating on the internet and so
i was getting on me over this and they
were like oh you're just a game of
thrones wire i was like well
i mean i was an intelligence officer at
the same time it's not publicly
um and then i'm like but that being said
i think it's actually quite useful
to understanding where we're going and
how we see things right
there is an aristocracy they are the
highborn they're different factions
right like the different houses
so certainly there are different
factions vying for power but
you would never see a member of one of
the houses of westeros allowing one of
the one of the they even call them the
small folk
there's a word for this in chinese it
means the old hundred names
um and and so there's the idea that they
they
are the rabble they are the deplorables
if you will
um and we are the elites we are those in
power
yeah why should why why should they
leave the world
the fate of the world in the hands of
people who eat
who you know who drink a quart of soda
with their
triple cheeseburgers mountain dew
you know i actually tell you sorry when
when i was in shanghai so
i was i was at the shanghai american
chamber of commerce and
there is a museum in they called a
museum certainly a museum they call it
the shanghai municipal planning
museum but it's actually more of a
planning center and
when so kodell's congressional
delegations or business delegations or
governors or senators whatever would
come to shanghai
they would always bring them to the
municipal planning center right and they
would say
into this museum and the ccp members so
this is the local shanghai
party and actually when i was there the
guy who was the chairman of the city
party of shanghai was a guy by the name
of xi jinping
right he's he's gone on to become a
little bit more prominent
congratulations
i know yeah good for him old buddies we
always knew
at the time i actually had the
opportunity to meet him once um and we
we always knew that he was going
up to politburo but we didn't realize it
was going to be that
big that fast um i always kind of
referred to him as he was like the you
know the shanghai tony soprano which is
how he carried himself it was huge
entourage you know
overcoat you know off-the-shoulder kind
of deal but
when they would bring our leaders there
right martin o'malley i remember
he came over when he was governor they
would take they would go down and they
would say wait a minute so
you guys if you decide you want a
financial sector you just
here's your your you can just draw on
the map and say this is going to be our
financial district and boom
you just have it within 10 years and
it's just there and if you want capital
it's just handed to you
and if you want a high-speed rail boom
you just get your high-speed rail and
you can
put it wherever you want you say you
want an entertainment center disney
wants a park right now shanghai disney
has a park
um so i was actually there for i was in
some of those early planning meetings
with disney
in shanghai as their meeting with the
ccp to say oh hey we're going to build
our park you want it here
and you know and then you know in the
back of my head i'm thinking
what about all the people who have lived
there those families these are these are
actually
there's a historic type of building that
they would have in old shanghai called
the shirakuman
and it's these there are these really
cool like interlocking
um houses and sort of like housing units
where you'd have a courtyard and then
around it uh people would go and then so
people could meet
kids would go in the courtyard and like
older couples would kind of hang out
there
took out sort of like watch over the
kids teach them things and then
if they were these communities everybody
was all stoned
right and i was like what's happening
with all them what about all those that
are there
wiped out destroyed demolished the
people
domain do they give them money or
anything no
just you
funny enough in china you can't own
anything right you can you cannot own
land
right you can lease it for about 99
years but the government always
owns all the land meaning this is taking
it actually
it is theirs it's already there actually
the word communism in mandarin
gong chan ju literally means
public property-ism right if you if you
translate it directly guangchan
uh it means public property so there is
so private ownership
is the opposite of community a little
aside have you guys ever heard or played
romance of the three kingdoms or read
the novel
i've read the novel yeah from 1600s
i one of the heroes is lube who's this
guy who wants to restore the han dynasty
the empire the emperor has fallen
and they all these warlords are vying
for power but this one guy who's kind of
the the the the moral hero of the story
wants to
restore the old empire and they make him
this like massive hero and i'm realizing
this is ccp prop this is propaganda man
this is imperial propaganda
we're supposed to love the hobby we
watched hero with jet li negative look
that's that's odd well spoiler that's
kind of the ending
what they've realized he's a rebel who
then joins the empire at the it's like
luke skywalker joining
the emperor at the end and killing his
friends yeah you know what's it called
hero
hero with jet lag so anyway just to
finish off my story though
are all the american leaders that would
come through shanghai they would say
this is great this is awesome how do i
get this how i want that
i want to bring that to the u.s right
they weren't going over there and
learning
and teaching china how to do things they
were going over there and saying
hey i want this back home yeah we need
some of that authority
we need more of this we need these
people with their little
their little lives they're just in our
way we're going to tell them
what's what we're going to get this type
of control
and that's exactly what started to
happen but let's ask
the audience with super chats if you
have not already smash that like button
it is greatly appreciated subscribe to
this channel share the show with your
friends and go to timcast.com become a
member we will have a
members only podcast coming up around 11
or so p.m but let's
read some of these super chats and take
questions beginning with
turk longwell says tim before twitter
banned me for loving america
i once got a poso bump from him
retweeting me sadly it only lasted him
lasted for a month still thanks jack
there you go
well you're very welcome and uh if
you're worried about bumps in the night
and you're worried about your sleep the
best way to be
knowing that you have an upgraded sleep
system is by going to mypillow.com
backslash poso and using promo code
posted the giza dream sleeves on yeah
there you go
right now do it yeah i told you i have
the slippers right actually
downstairs i got it i got it for my dad
i got for my dad for father's day he
won't take him off
yeah there's them everywhere they're
legit good all right brandizzle says
please google preparing for a hurricane
and take a look at the suggested
guidelines i think you will find it
informative
i've seen it that's right it says get
vaccinated what
wait what yeah yeah
all right
all right let's see we got alexander
dominguez says this is different than
the u.s going to the middle east the
people of cuba overwhelmingly want the
us there
help us end communism in our country
what if cuba became the 51st state
it's like puerto rico and guam i love
the idea from a distance without knowing
much about it i don't know
there's a lot of talk about it i mean
being republican i mean you don't have
to go back very far
to the 1950s 1959 as the revolution
but you don't have to go back far even
um in in the musical uh
uh with the guys and dolls right there's
actually a scene in there where they
just fly from new york to havana
and he takes this girl on the date sky
master and takes her out on this date
and so it was just seen as like some a
place you could go
in the caribbean very easily um and so
there was actually talk of
funny enough the confederacy was talking
about conquering cuba at one point and
turning yeah and
and using that as a readout in a very
you know kind of an eerie
sort of like mirror version of what
happened with taiwan and china right
they were talking about taking over cuba
and making that a confederate state at
one point
did you see the uh story about the
george floyd mural
the lightning yeah i saw that let me
tell you a story so the other day
after we finished the show cassandra
messaged me and she's like whoa and it's
a story
george floyd mural destroyed by
lightning strike doppler radar confirms
a lightning strike occurred in the area
around 4 30 p.m
and the building is structurally sound
the building is still totally fine it's
the outer brick wall that got blown out
by the lightning strike
only the george floyd mural and i
checked immediately
you know what i did i checked the
weather in toledo for that day
and it was sunny all day except for this
moment where a storm gathered over the
building
lightning struck the mural and then
immediately the storm dissipates
and like when you look at the photos you
can see the ground is mostly dry and
there's like a little bit of water
liking to the discoloration a little bit
and it's like
the weather said it was sunny with
scattered clouds all day no reported
rain
yet rain forms lightning strikes the
building and then the rain leaves
so a lot of people are like immediately
saying i'm gonna go to church on sunday
this time well
you know you know you got to say with a
story like that holy toledo
dude i've worked out i've spent time
moving the clouds i mean they're elected
we're bodies where i have
electromagnetic and you know toruses of
energy
dynamo and the clouds are also
lightweight electromagnetic energy i've
had
very explicit events where clouds have
spun
like i was working out and the clouds
start to spin and then part and you can
see the moon in a whole
i mean we are connected to this planet
in so many ways
i don't know about that the schumann
resonance is this weird like extremely
low frequency of resonance
in our injections look at each other on
the upper magnetosphere of earth but i
mean
lightning i think it's more connected to
human consciousness
yeah yeah the magnetosphere and you're
not storm you don't control the waves
it's just a guess but i think in a
thousand years they'll be like wow they
didn't
have no idea they thought it was just
some that it was just there they didn't
realize
well i'll say this look the simple the
simple solution with stories like this
is like
buildings get struck by lightning all
the time and we don't care like it's not
news
but this one happened to have a mural on
it so all of a sudden we're like oh it's
a sign it's an it's an act of god or
whatever
well i think insurance companies would
call an act of god you know so
their insurance will pay for it whether
or not it's actually a sign
from some divine creator i i'll tell you
it's a
crazy story there's like ancient history
i mean was there anything metallic
on the you know the side there what
that's what i'm trying to think like
what attracted
or it's like when you know when we take
our kids to the um
you know the pool we have a pool we take
them and but you know just the other day
there was a
you know there was some thunder and it
was like okay out of the pool yeah just
straight up get out of the pool
does it you know come we're going to go
inside so you know i'm just wondering if
there's something
they've got the native american rain
dance i mean they believed they could
call the rain ancient chinese warriors
societies around the world believed that
there was a direct connection between
human action and weather that is that i
mean
the butterfly effect hey how about that
one all right archangel says first super
chat i love the show and everyone on it
jack what is your favorite sabaton song
and album
uh i mean my favorite song is the winged
hustlers obviously
uh favorite hair of an album probably
last stand i'd have to go with that i'm
still just debating whether i want to go
see them twice or
three times on their upcoming tour tough
call
all right let's see sorta oh i can't
read your name but thanks to the super
chat
says uh tim would you be willing to
bring on edward snowden julian assange
or beau bergdahl bring on some bring on
the dissidents
bill bergdahl was not a dissident yeah
who's bob bergadol
bo bergdahl is a guy who deserted and
tried to join the television yeah oh
not great i definitely would not put him
in the same category yeah snowden and
julian assange i'm familiar with
bergdahl not so much
uh maybe i mean perhaps they meant
manning
yeah perhaps they met chelsea who's
going to say eli manning the chelsea
manning story is uh
is really interesting because you know
when chelsea goes into prison
coming out the entire left right
paradigm was mirrored and completely
fractured like wikileaks was now the bad
guy
so what do you do in that situation
where you're like you're on the left
you're like go wikileaks i'll support
you the left is in this weird position
where there were like pro chelsea
manning
but anti-julian assange right
whereas it's like wait what but they
together created what you know became
you know
that old chelsea manning cassandra
fairbanks thing was really twisted stuff
what was it
i mean i i can't go through the whole
story about it but they were uh
i'm i don't want to speak too much i'm
friends with cassandra and i don't know
exactly what happened but
i think it's just like they were friends
because uh
cassandra very much supports wikileaks
and chelsea but then chelsea was
anti-fun cassandra was a trump supporter
so there was this weird
like thing that happened and i guess
something happened like chelsea claiming
she was infiltrating the right or
something like that i don't know
she showed up to the i was there um it
was at the
night for freedom in new york city um i
actually was the person who made sure
that uh she had a comp ticket and was
able to get in my brother was was
manning the door and i said hey
uh manning um and i said hey just so you
know
chelsea manny's gonna come in i know
there's some there is some antique
outside but
you know just you know here's a photo
just so you know let me give me a call
to make sure everything's cool and we
had uh
i think we had like buzzfeed there and a
guy who
uh charlie roselle who he's now and he
was a new york times writer now he's
like a subs that guy
uh who was there and we had a guy from
new yorker who was there and so
suddenly it became this huge thing that
you know chelsea manning's at this event
with the new right and and then chelsea
right yeah yeah um and then and then
chelsea had to put out this big disc
like oh no it was it was an infiltration
operation
i was there to you know find out and
it's like it was a public event
like we sold tickets think about what
there was there was a lot of people
whose they one day woke up to find
that their friends on the left had
completely
flipped and i know this first hand i
know a lot of people have experienced
this
and i guess if you are moderately weak
willed
it's brain breaking so there's like uh i
i i'm friends with a ton of uh or i
should say
yeah i still would consider myself to be
friends with a lot of the old hacker
community a lot
of these more prominent hackers and
things like that many although mostly
it's like kind of broken up quite a bit
the the og hackers from like the the
late 2000s or i shouldn't say og but
like some of the prominent hackers of
that day
anonymous type individuals telecomics
these people who are heavily involved
have stayed true to their principles and
are still friends a lot of people
but a very large sect of the hacker
community became authoritarian
leftist and it's really weird like at
the hope event it's called hackers on
planet earth
they threw out a guy because they had a
maga hat on at first the security guards
were like we don't care if you're in the
magazine like the hacker community is
is subversive anti-establishment but all
of a sudden like core elements of the
hacker community were very much like
egad trump supporters oh we must support
the fbi and the establishment
so you have to imagine there are these
people in the early
i mean it's it's crazy to look back i
love referencing rap news i think number
six
because it was a left wing video
praising julian assange
criticizing hillary clinton and showing
alex jones as a character by the way
claiming
the commie nazi fascists are coming now
i guess alex jones is called the fascist
hillary clinton was the good guy
julian assange was the bad guy really
amazing to see that 10 years ago
that was the left yeah now that's the
right if i i've been saying this for
years
if juice media okay the juice media guys
put out a ton of left wing videos
leftist videos
if they made rap news today they would
be called far right fascists
no joke go watch rap news 6. it's
hilarious
it's amazing it's pro julian assange
it's about cablegate it's from 2010 i
think
and you can see how the left used to be
pro free speech
auntie hillary clinton and anyway
there's one you're missing though
isn't it kind of interesting and when i
talk about this idea of the overstate
right george w
bush is suddenly treated
as if he's like on this team they love
him
i love him he goes on ellen he does all
this different stuff and it's like
we've we've just welcomed him back this
was a guy
who i'm old enough to remember all of
the bush years right
i mean he was hitler yeah he was a nazi
he was a war criminal he was the guy who
leiden got us into it
actually did lie to get us in iraq by
the way um and all of these different
things
he was the scum of the earth but
but but at least and this goes back to
my earlier contentions the game of
thrones thing
highborn versus the lowborn and i was
just by the way up in southern maine
where the bushes have their
kennebunkport
you know of course they're oh excuse me
no no they're from texas right they're
from texas they don't have a
a big new england hideout where they
hang out even though he's born in
connecticut
um they are part of the highborn they
are part of the aristocracy right
so even though that they one faction was
completely against him
right he still maintains his prestige
his
and this is by the way actual privilege
right right right they're
not talking about like like like sjw uh
you know well look political racer
approves this
actual privilege it's like you know you
might fight with people in your family
but you don't let like you could be
yelling about how your sister is dumb
and she stole your stereo or something
but then when you know so the kid at
high school insults your sister you say
i'm talking about my sister
that way right but then you go home and
say the same thing about it right
so the highborn very much are like
george w bush is trash
and then when it comes the highborne
versus the the was it lowborn is that
what the newborn yeah
then all of a sudden they're like leave
him alone he's one of us all right we
got one from blackrock beacon he says
ian thank you for telling everyone what
blackrock refers to mythologically
scrying to uncover hidden truth it's why
i used it for my media brand blackrock
beacon you are awesome and i i
highly recommend if anyone is interested
with the obsidian yeah this is the black
rock
the scrying the scrying stone it's
really interesting it feels
like i i use crystal balls as well this
volcanic glass i don't know if it's
crystal i don't think it's crystal um
but you can store heat in it
you know use reiki but i mean it's just
i don't know about all that it is
oh you will reiki put it in your palm
dude just you just cradle it in your
palm
all right the civic nationalist says i
think everyone forgets how the 1930s
german
nsdap got into power it wasn't a violent
takeover it was a slow 10-year process
to the camps
everyone should remember that not a shot
but thunderous applause
stay safe u.s and i think we're watching
that happen and what did they use
what do they use they used uh to pass
the reichstag there was
it was the reichstag the burning
proclamation it was the enabling act
it was an assault on their parliament
that they used to say
we need to pass these emergency measures
they're just just it's just to stop
the current insurrection right
this these playbooks have been played
out so many times in the past
you don't need to go back and i'm not
one of those guys you have to compare
everything to the 1930s but
in that one specific instance you can
actually see it was an assault on their
capital
which they used to declare emergency
september 11th man they nailed the
pentagon or whatever the pentagon got
hit by a plane or whatever the story is
um and then
the patriot act got signed all of our
civil liberties essentially that's like
the enabling act of the twenty first
then ten years later barack obama signed
the indefinite detention provisions the
national defense authorization act which
allows the us government
to effectively rendition anyone anywhere
for any reason
permanently so that could be you and
your bed at night just
black bag like creedy yeah no and and
i'll say this straight up right i was a
guy who
who joined the intel community i said i
thought boy this is this is the way i'm
saying i'm saving america i'm keeping
people safe this is the way to do it
right
um you know you know we have these
powers we have these tools but we're you
know we're we're using them against the
bad guys
right so we'll not we would never you
know never use this against our own
people
that'd be crazy right right so it's okay
that the us has these these problems
ersky has these powers
now i'm i'm here to say civil
libertarians were a hundred
percent right on that or really anyone
who lived through the vietnam era or
understands the vietnam era 100
right all right josh lotovsky says we
should ask elon to smuggle starlinks
into cuba to let the people get the word
out to bypass the government censorship
the one issue currently starlink are
there they're set locked so
each individual link can only connect to
one satellite
yeah it's a bomber so until they
activate the actual satellites
it's it's like they're slowly
implementing one at a time uh what they
really would need is uh mesh networks
right so with with mesh networks you can
set up your own communication sphere
one that the only way the government
would be able to get into it is if they
have
access to your direct mesh network and
if you have encryption that they can't
break and you can change that up enough
um i have no background in this
whatsoever from the military um
that uh you know that essentially they'd
be able to get some comes up or
um like what what they were doing in
iran they were essentially setting up
like you know how we have airdrop you
know where it's this sort of like
bluetooth
enabled communications they were able to
use i forgot what the app was
but it now allows you to create a text
messaging within
you know maybe like 100 meters or so
that you can get something across that's
not going over any network
all right media says jack are you aware
of the fat leonard scandal from com log
westpac
i was stationed yeah yeah 100 wild story
what was that i never forgot i'll never
forget the uh lady gaga
tickets were part of that what what uh
so oh man it's it's so hard to break
this
it's a long story it's it's a super long
story but essentially it comes down
and in the fast way to break it down is
essentially
that when a ship pulls into port
somewhere
the question of which company so this
this bleeds into
that military industrial comp uh complex
but
in terms of not only domestic companies
but also international companies when
when a u.s navy ship has to pull in
somewhere right
uh then okay who fuels the ship where do
they get their food
where do they get any any of the
supplies i mean you're talking about an
aircraft carrier just one
aircraft carrier that's 5 000 people
that is a floating
city right not to mention all the other
crews that might be on it contractors
etc etc
so who gets the money how are those
contracts done this is all this is all
called
uh this is sourcing and procurement so
the procurement process for this
uh and with fat leonard he was this i
believe his malaysian guy who was just
bribing hell out of admirals and
captains and anyone up and down the
chain
in that procurement uh background that
to make sure that it was always his
people and his companies that got
involved
so he got busted and he was i always
remember that one of the things they
used to bribe was like lady gaga tickets
amazing but it was it was big you know
actually uh some pretty big name people
went down over that
wow logan culver says michael malus is a
term for the wii
it's the cathedral so i think i think
cathedral is
uh i've heard that term as well um i
know that he's not he's not the only
person who uses that i just
i also think that it's i think it's a
bit too esoteric for some people right
to think well you know what the
cathedral is like a place right
and it's a good time you have to kind of
understand the history of what it's
referring to
right so you do need a lot of
understanding for that and i might was a
smart guy
i don't get me wrong i i think it's a
great term when you get real smart you
start getting a bit esoteric
but it is i think it's a little too
esoteric and that's why because though
the reason i say overstate is because
it's sort of a play-off of the deep
state right yeah what's the difference
right so what is the difference right
great example so the deep state
if you understand that term that's sort
of like that that typically i think
people refer to the
bureaucracy in in our government right
they would refer to that and say well
this is
you know the the underlings the sort of
the permanent class the administrative
divisions of the us government that
originally were supposed to just be
subservient to the president in the
executive branch
but now have grown and this is the very
wilsonian idea of an expansive
executive where they have just become
this own organic state
right and this is this is the
progressive small p progressive uh
vision for how a state it's a very
german idea by the way that the state
would become its own organism
that would be self-perpetuating and it's
very similar to the british
civil service um however the overstate
that gets into all of these other facets
of power right these other nodes of
power that all seem to be working in
concert with one another so
the fact is that it goes beyond just
what we know
as an official government agency or a
government body
but all these other nodes of power that
are able to then filter in and make
these decisions so when lina wen
who's you know okay she's the former
president of planned parenthood but
she's not a government
uh official in any capacity she's not
elected in any capacity to anything
and yet she has power she has him so
zuckerberg not deep state overstated
overstate
and and because in in a very real sense
they are
super national like supra they are above
the state
all right german would be uber james
nelson says schism occurred in 2008 with
election of obama
anyone who opposed his policies was
labeled racist by msm
one uh it's a tea party formed to push
back first time cons
stood up called racist trump elected
deplorables
i could say it goes back to 2000 when
you literally had this legal battle over
the presidency
and people were like not my president
and they were fighting george
george w bush got in and they screamed
he was hitler and all this other stuff
remember selected not elected yeah that
was the big there was a big reference
like
hail to the hill to the thief the
important thing to understand is this
all actually goes back to
um everything can be traced back to one
simple thing
thomas jefferson saying that
the revolution needed the support of
south carolina and georgia thus he
removed the anti-slavery
statements from the declaration of
independence and then from there you
ended up with
conflict between northern states and
southern states and then the parties
became the democrats and the republicans
which ultimately formed basically
the democratic party existed they were
the democratic republicans but then the
civil war starts
we've basically never left the civil war
if you really look at the policies the
conflict the political divisions and the
parties
it's like it's it's all it's not in
terms of parties not in terms of
regions what i mean no no no this is not
meant to be some profound statement it's
basically just
everything is derivative of something
you know what i mean when they're like
oh it all started here in 2008 it's like
2000 and you go back to clinton then why
would clinton get elected why did you
know reagan get elected and remember
clinton and this is something that i
think a lot of people
miss when they talk about clinton he was
a southern governor
that's right right arkansas yeah right
and now hillary remember i don't have to
move down little rock you know
you know but that he was a because so he
was seen as
and and you know i don't know people are
going to get hit me hit me on this flat
he was more of a centrist president um
particularly after
the 1994 uh revolution because newt
gingrich basically made him be more of a
centrist balance the budget
uh pushed for particularly conservative
or so you would say social conservative
issues of the day
uh tipper gore was pro-censorship you
know uh
she was she was sent censoring remember
um parental guidance
stickers on all of your cd cases and you
knew if you got the
provincial guidance one that that was
the good one that was the good version
that was the one you wanted all right
eric that was democrats that was all
democrats and al gore tennessee
yeah you know i fully agree with this uh
obama thing i was thinking this while we
were talking about it earlier
i had a lot of friends that were like
ready to be radical to overturn this
corrupt system in 2007.
and then obama came we're like this is
the guy he's going to let us do it he's
not going to stop us it wasn't obama it
was george w bush i think he's selected
but when
when obama was in if there was a moment
where i realized he was got co-opted
when he was like trans-pacific
partnership and
other people didn't see it and those
people went on to become
now this was this wasn't there an
interview like right when obama won the
senate seat he was asked if he was gonna
run for president and he was like oh
you know maybe or something like that
yeah with 2000
there was a split in the country fairly
evenly
w bush won half the country said this is
bs
bush got us involved in a bunch of wars
and then they were like
obama is that revolution and then al
gore would have got us involved in the
executive of course of course
exactly i i always laugh when people say
oh bush
al gore the machine you don't think it
was cheney you think it was bigger
deeper
i i think it was way machine bro right
you can't
it's it's it's tempting to want to try
to pin this on like one person
but it's it's not right these are
powerful machines these are power
machines all right aaron says jack you
convey what's happening so simply the
value of that cannot be overstated
i just dropped a podcast on how the left
is dividing us in two separate nations
with separate flags and anthems can i
get a shout out for
into the fray podcast hey there you go
buddy i
i completely agree you know the flags um
situation
is that's that's i mean that's a direct
blow right
um you can now go and when you see
houses
and they have an american flag there is
a greater chance that that will be a
republican
or at least a veteran who's who's in
that house right as and then having
other flags other anthems right these
are
huge problems right when it comes to
national cohesion
it would not even have been considered
when i was growing up in the 90s it
wouldn't have even been it was beyond
the pale to even
we're there maybe such a thing all right
milk reit says hey tim any chance of
getting larry elder or tiffany meyer on
the show
also what would you rate the epoch times
in ntd news credibility wise
um not super familiar with uh uh i i've
read uh a decent amount of epoch uh uh
epic times and i think so epoch you're
sure they've been epic
that's how you spell epic for like the
epics of history pretty sure it's epic
because there's a commercial where they
call it
they themselves call it epic times i see
epoch yeah um the articles i've read
from them have been fairly good but i
know newsguard says they're they're
they're
fake news but not that news guard is the
end all be all the articles i've seen
from them have actually been pretty
decent i've been reading
so when i lived in china all those years
ago um
it was about 15 years and i would say
like i want to learn more about the ccp
i want to learn more about
just from a historical standpoint right
and now it's and i'd go to chinese
sources and it would all be pro-ccp
and then i would say all right well let
me read some western newspapers and see
what they're talking about
and that was all pro ccp and i was
digging around so there's got to be
somebody who's just talking about like
where's all that stuff i learned about
in history class where's the the
massacres of chairman mao and the great
leap forward and all these other things
epoch times yeah i found them 15 years
ago and i was reading them and saying
like they were the only ones who were
actually just telling the truth
interesting all right lamer says the
scariest thing about societal collapse
is that there is no coming back
there are no energy sources that can
fuel an industrial civilization that can
that can be reached without modern
technology we fall and we don't get back
up
i don't necessarily agree i think
typically what you see with societal
collapse is that many of the
the knowledge persists and the constr
well i'll put it blunt after the the
black plague when most of the population
got wiped out
the knowledge of the technology they had
remained and they were able to then
implement that and then they flourish
and there was a renaissance and things
like that although the roman when the
empire
fell apart a lot of that technology was
lost a lot of like how to build
octoducts and
sewage and all the underwater cement and
we had like interesting the dark ages
it was actually i was at this uh uh this
sort of like off the book summit
recently with um some pretty high level
people and this one guy
um he said you know looking at things
the way i look at things
is it's it's kind of interesting where
it seems like all the people who are in
power
now like it's like they've been handed
the keys but not the instruction manual
yeah
and the instruction or the memo like
just put like each generation is
supposed to write a memo to the next
generation
or that sort of history of like
presidents writing letters to their
successors
or in like national treasure they have
the president's book remember that's
like a big like the secrets of the
country
but it's almost like the memo got lost
and so the people who are in control now
just have no clue what they're doing
they've lost
they've lost the memo the memo got lost
somewhere i think it's because we're
putting people in power by popularity
contests
we're getting a bunch of idiots in power
no it's just because they
people like them yeah but it's an elite
club who who's able to run you know
right
but i mean that's there's there's the
politicians and then there's the people
in power oh
chris atkins says i have to know how do
you feel about crowders change my mind
i have never once seen him demand that
someone sit down only willing
participants
yeah it's an excellent show it's very
smart i think he originally called it
real conversations
great meme just hands down really yeah
totally
i wanted to do something and i think we
will something akin to like real
conversations the goal is
to interview regular people out in these
different cities
not to change their minds or ours but to
literally be like what do you think
about these things
and then just show like find someone
who's conservative like left right and
independent and then just have them like
generally talk and do a podcast where
it's like
so how do you feel about this wow
interesting how do you feel about that
and just kind of keep it real keep it
raw i'd love to do that but maybe
you know and then at the end i'm like
okay but did you realize that the one
that you picked
was a my pillow
it was more comfortable all right
hex mayor says hey tim hamm radio
operator here cuba is actively
jamming the 40 meter frequency band
right now not only did they kill the
internet
but actively affecting worldwide
communications to stop info
what crazy yeah my my dad was a big cp
guy uh growing up and so
you know you know he always showed us
how to do that we had the big antenna on
the roof
um and then it back then it was like hey
i'm talking to a guy in norway
i'm talking a guy in jamaica you know
and be able to and that idea of
you can be able to get a whole i'm
driving around you know truckers and
stuff like that
but the idea of being able to like he
instilled in me that the importance of
being able
to have communications and have that
network that and radio is
is just out there right it's not
something that anyone can unless you jam
it right if you have state you'd need
state power to be able to do something
like that
um but for the most part and you can go
do another channel but you have to get
everyone
on that channel to find it but it's that
idea of you know
any societal collapse type situation
that these are the types of
communication might hello my that my dad
was actually a ytk guy do you
we're gonna we're looking at getting an
i2k guy like a ham radio or like a
shortwave radio or something
but i was looking at him there's a huge
array of them cost wise to up to like 20
grand you can see these massive
do you do you have any experience do you
think or if anyone out there knows and
wants to give me some advice on twitter
which one should i get because we could
like encode we can encode
what our frequency band is you know if
if it really hits the fan
i will i will talk to my dad and we'll
set it up all right everybody thanks for
hanging out smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends
you can follow us on facebook and
instagram at tim cast irl
we uh we got deleted from tiktok briefly
all our videos were deleted and then i
tweeted lol tick-tock deleted all our
videos
and then a few minutes later after
tweeting it they put them all back up
to
and then all of a sudden it just
reappeared after i tweeted about it
i wonder if what really i don't know i
don't know what happened i i really
don't
correlation is not causation yeah well
they all the videos are just gone
so think about it the videos are going
to the account was no the account was
there
all the videos were gone wow and then i
tweeted about it
and then a few minutes or after that
like a half an hour just they all came
back could have been a bug
never know no they were gone for a few
hours just a glitch
and when another account we had tried to
test upload similar content it was also
removed
yeah and other content on the site was
available i think it was i think because
i tweeted about it and it created a
stink and people started saying woo
and you know some people were like we're
going to write about it we'll see what
happens then all of a sudden it comes
back
they said what they said they said woo
yeah
yeah um people are like why are you on
tick tock because we go where the
culture war is happening yeah it's like
if if there's a culture war happening
we'll
send the message it's kind of
interesting when people are like yeah
but you know tik tok is chinese like why
would you or
china like why would you want to go it's
a communist party on that platform i'm
like
if we have people in china who are pro
freedom or hong kong don't we want to
send them messages and let them know
what's happening guess who's listening
to you on google
and i know anything else it's like okay
the cia gets you here mss gets you there
but we're just trying to make sure that
we're not going to be like i refuse to
engage in this area because
it's controlled by this group well no
let's flood them flood the zone with
smack talking the chinese communist
party that's fantastic yes so anyway
follow me personally at tim cast
and of course we do the show monday
through friday live we're gonna we're
gonna have a bonus segment up at
timcast.com so go become a member
you want to shout anything out jack yeah
yeah you know i
i plugged my pill a whole bunch we
actually are doing something uh we
actually
do have a page ups on mypillow.composo
um we're going to be putting just
exclusive deals up there one cool thing
i actually got my son
um it's bible story so if you're someone
who's christian
it's just bible stories for kids it's
like a little pillow um we got him jesus
there's also there's like noah
daniel the lion just a bunch of cool
different things and then for all latest
news updates etc it's humanevents.com
ton of stuff coming out working on a
scoop that i can't get into too much
right now i was like halfway done it
so i think i'm probably going to finish
it in the morning but it has to do
with the department of justice and inner
city crime and what they are teaching
people
from the highest levels of the doj and
the white house about
right on well times may be confusing but
we can do this together
as humans we're extremely innovative
technology is at our fingertips so let's
use it and if you want to get a piece of
obsidian i highly recommend it it's not
like any other stone i've ever held in
my hand i really like it game of thrones
uh
obsidian is like the main uh mystical
really
you know it's it's what kills the white
walkers and the others but they don't
call it obsidian
dragon glass yeah right right love it so
get your piece of dragonglass
love you guys may follow me on twitter
at sour patch lids as i attempt to have
more followers than
uh sour patch kids i just want to say to
all you people questioning why we're on
places like youtube and tick tock
we are there because we're attempting to
draw people to our site
which is our attempt to combat on the
culture wars
like playing field to get them off those
sites and to get into our
our own uh site but yeah
you guys are welcome to follow me on
twitter at sourpatchlitz jesus said go
where the centers are
that's right we will see all of you at
timcast.com thanks for hanging out
you